up next author and consumer advocate
ralph nader joins book tv for a
three-hour in-depth interview
the three-time presidential candidate
and grassroots activist is the author or
co-author of more than 20 books
including coarse collision in pursuit of
justice and his seminal work unsafe at
any speed
mr nader's latest work is his first
novel only the super rich can save us
ralph nader why do you start off your
childhood memoir with the story about
the cruelty of eight
grade boys
well i've never forgotten that
episode we were
in eighth grade and we were finishing
the day sort of rushing out of the
school
uh with my friends and one of them
looked at a girl who was going out and
and said uh look at that uh pig
and which in those days meant a girl who
was unattractive
and uh she was with us since the first
great and she was a wonderful person
friendly helpful always there
and she just
was stunned she overheard him and just
walked the other way and of course the
boys then ran out of the door walking
home
i said to myself what what's her crime i
mean how can anybody they were just
going into puberty so they were fit and
i realized that
there's a lot of bigotry about the way
people look and and it's it's one of the
forms of discrimination it's almost
never talked about
look at the people who sit behind the
desk at a reception for a big company
when you walk in and then look to people
who are waiting to clean your airplane
when you walk out so has economic
psychological consequences i've always
tried to fight against that in fact one
of our books called being beautiful
tries to do that redefine beauty beyond
skin deep body shape
to be character personality wit friend
friendliness
it's very important to do that there's
so much
ground level
agony and
young people
wanting to commit suicide because they
think their nose is too long or their
ears are floppy and they're laughed at
by their friends and even in older ages
you know brown spots
i don't think we should focus on this if
we focus on character and personality
and what people do
in writing the 17 traditions you
probably for the first time exposed a
little bit of your private self to
people what what do you want people to
take away from this book
that they have traditions in their own
families their parents grandparents
great-grandparents that they really
should put down whether by
recording or writing
before it's too late to connect to the
younger generation that's now
electronically saturated with the
gadgets and is not connected so a lot of
history is basically what people
ordinary people think do say a lot of
hidden wisdom a lot of hidden insights
and so we have this website we had it uh
17traditions.org
urging people to send us an insight or
an experience or a piece of wisdom from
your background family and
and to encourage them to do the same
thing themselves and in fact your 17
traditions in your in the nader family
listening the family table health
history scarcity
sibling equality
education and argument discipline simple
enjoyments reciprocity
independent thinking
charity work
business patriotism solitude and civics
let's start with number 15
patriotism what's your definition of
patriotism it wasn't flag waving my
parents were immigrants and they were
bridled from lebanon and and they
bridled at the expectation of people
just
thinking that if you sing the right
songs and
of the flag that that's patriotism to my
mother and father patriotism came in the
form of ralph eight years old do you
love your country why of course mom well
i hope when you grow up you'll spend
time making it more lovable so
patriotism was
having a more just country a more
accessible country a country with higher
expectations and public participation in
self-government
and that that was drummed into me when i
was working with my dad in the
restaurant it was like an all-purpose
town meeting all the time
and he would have those conversations
thousands of people going through town
sales people jurors from the county
courthouse this is winstead connecticut
winston yeah
and uh
and you see they were all about deeds
they they hated rhetoric and words and
slogans like that they were what did you
what are you doing with your life are
you going to the town meeting are you
going to the neighborhood group
are you just staying home are you
assuming your civic responsibilities
because together and it's only together
that we can build a a just and happy
society another one of those traditions
independent thinking
yeah well that was a trademark of my uh
dad and mother they they uh they were
very very difficult uh converts to
propaganda let me tell you i mean they'd
see right through a politician uh we had
a long counter in the restaurant and
politicians always come because the
perfect place to campaign you just shake
hands with all the factory workers and
others that are there and they would go
right down the counter uh shaking it hey
i'm selling some running for the office
hi hi how are you how are you how are
you and my father would be at the coffee
urn at the end he couldn't believe this
mechanical type painting so he'd get the
the candidate would get to my father and
say how are you my father wouldn't let
go of the hand and he said i want to
talk with you i i want these people to
hear what are your views on this why
didn't you do that
so it is the whole tradition of
independent thinking was part of our
growing up
in indepen in the 17 traditions you also
discuss how your mother
did not let go of a politician's hand at
one point yeah that's now become a
famous story that was prescott bush
senator from connecticut grandfather
george w bush
and
we had recurrent floods in the town and
the mad river which is well named would
flood up and and
ruin the main street and there were
losses of life and 1955 had a big one
and she'd had enough of of politicians
talking about a dry dam up at the river
you know so the water could be backed up
uh and it wouldn't rush in into the
gully of the river and then over into
the streets so she heard that fresco
bush was coming to town to campaign she
went there waited in line she got up to
him he said you know he was going the
usual high how are you here's a
patrician type demeanor and she looked
up at him and she wouldn't let his hand
go and he was trying you know you know
that was awkward she said i want you to
promise me because you know about this
devastating flood senator bush that
you'll build a dry dam you'll get the
corps of engineers to build a dry dam
and a dry dam was built and we've never
had a flood since so her idea of how do
you deal with politicians because they
hardly ever listen and they're always
far away so you ever get to them when
they're campaigning you want to
get their ear
grab their hand and don't let go
another one of the 17 traditions you
write about ralph nader is scarcity
yes they thought too much abundance too
many toys too many this too much that
spoiled would spoil children so they
made sure that we had the necessities
but we weren't overflowing with them
and
i i really treasure that
uh we went to the movies once in a while
for example the strand theater
we didn't have
three different kinds of baseball gloves
and we were taught to make some of the
things instead of buy them
listening
well that was the most important of
course that's the one that families who
read the book
resonate the most that's why i have it
at the top
uh my mother always felt that
uh if you didn't listen you couldn't
learn
it was just that simple if if you kept
talking talking talking as some people
do they're constantly talking
they're not learning and so she she of
course it helped with the discipline too
ralph nader is our in-depth guest this
is book tv's monthly three-hour program
with one author
looking at his or her body of work and
we invite your participation in this
program you'll see the numbers up on the
screen divided by geographical location
202 is the area code for those in the
east and central time zone
737-01 is the number for you to call
737-02 for those of you in the mountain
and pacific time zone you can also send
ralph nader an email at booktv at
cspan.org or follow us and send a tweet
at twitter.combooktv
our handle is book tv ralph nader is the
author or co-author of about 20 books it
all began with unsafe at any speed
ralph nader how did this book get
started
well it got started because i hitchhiked
a lot all over the country and
once in a while truck drivers would pick
me up we'd be first at the scene of a
horrific crash before the ambulances and
the police
and i've never i've never forgotten
those scenes i mean screams
severed limbs blood
sudden silence
it's a
it was a memorable uh thing but i i
began to notice uh
things about a car how the steering
column would ram right back into the
driver like a spear so i got to harvard
law school and my third year i did a did
a study on unsafe automobile design
engineering design there were no seat
belts there was no head restraints no
stronger door latches no padded dash
panels no collapsible steering columns
the way we have today no airbags
obviously seat belts
and uh
and i made a recommendation that there
should be mandatory safety standards
there were no mandatory safety standards
these at state level except for brake
fluid
or at the federal level and yet it was
the fourth leading cause of death in
america and the first leading cause of
death for
youngsters from age 5 to 24.
so i decided to dig into it uh beyond my
this is while you're in law school yes
and then after law school i continue
collecting material i mean people can
collect in in
one month more material now there's so
much out on automobile safety
than i was able to collect in years uh
that's how we've progressed and so i
wrote the book
in the process i came to the attention
of general motors who hired private
detectives to get dirt on me and to
follow me they made a mistake they
followed me down to the senate office
building they were caught by the local
police
who were often third year law students
by the way working the good old days and
they caught the detective
and it was a big story in the washington
post and then rob robert irvine who's a
great uh automotive reporter for the
detroit news systematically called up
every auto company say did you do this
american motors no did you do this
chrysler no did you do this ford no did
you do this general motors no comment
and then they had to admit it there were
great congressional hearings in the
senate senator ribacov senator kennedy
was involved senator harris oklahoma and
in just a matter of months literally we
got federal regulation of the auto
industry mandatory standards for safety
for fuel efficiency and recall of
defective cars authority now that took
nine months from november
1965 when the book came out until
september when lyndon johnson signed the
bill the following year
president truman proposed universal
health care in the 1940s we still don't
have it
why do you think i think what do you
think the difference is i think and it's
it's a strategy that i put in my book
only the super rich can save us fast you
have to when you do reforms you simply
can't say well we'll lay the groundwork
year one year two year three because the
opposition corporations know how to
counter attack they know how to
lay the groundwork with members of
congress they know how to propagandize
the idea of doing something quickly that
is uh
involving a long recognized need not
some new technology a wrong long
recognized need uh was i think a reason
for the success plus the fact that the
auto companies didn't have a lobbying
presence in washington because they
didn't have to worry about anything
and so they weren't in gear so to speak
they were gearing up in that period
from unsafe at any speed
vehicle deficiencies are more important
to correct than human inadequacies
simply because they are easier to
analyze and to remedy and whether
motorists are momentarily careless or
intoxicated or are driving normally when
they are struck by another vehicle is
entirely irrelevant to the
responsibility of the automobile makers
to build safe cars
yeah they can't in the auto companies
they can't say well because drivers
often fall asleep or are drinking we
don't have to produce cars that have
good brakes good handling
good tires and above all crash worthy
protection like padded dash panels and
collapsing steering columns seat belts
airbags i want to shift the
responsibility
a good deal of it obviously drivers have
a responsibility highway designers and
builders have responsibility but in this
case i wanted to shift it on to the
greatest way to prevent death and injury
and the the results have been
spectacular when this book came out
the death toll for 100 million vehicle
miles was about 5.6 fatalities it's now
1.4
5.6 1.4 we'd be losing 200 more 200 000
people a year instead it's just under
40. do you know how many how many copies
it sold in 1965 or 1966 i think with the
paperback sold over 150 000
and got a lot of attention oh yeah it
was page one new york times and
is it your best-selling book of all your
books yes
um
you've been writing now for 40 45 years
your most recent book 2009 only the
super rich can save us is a novel how
did you get to a novel well by the way i
think maybe who runs congress sold more
yeah who runs but but i just introduced
that and it was written by mark green
and others
uh
well i uh you know people are pretty
frustrated in the country there's
gridlock in washington
wall street
controls washington beyond anything i've
ever seen every department agency so
many members of congress are taking
money there are top officials from
corporations in high government
positions
department of treasury department
defense department
various departments and
i think people are demoralized and i
think they feel they're powerless and
they don't know what to do about it you
get these fits of anger like out of the
tea party and so forth and so i i
thought we have to raise our expectation
level and we have to imagine a different
kind of realistic future and the best
way to do it
was this form of political fiction it's
not a novel it's a it's called
a a work of political uh imagination it
used real life 17
super rich people like warren buffett
george soros ted turner yoko ono
william gates senior in fictional roles
and they decide they're going to put a
lot of money and a lot of their
influence be beyond behind the people in
this country right down to the community
level congressional districts to turn
our country around well i want to tie
that to your 17 traditions book you tell
a story in 17 traditions about your
father driving you around winstead
connecticut to see some of the
sites where people have donated money
the library for example is is one where
somebody gave money and winstead had a
uh memorial library
and
he goes on to say that well there are
several
hundreds uh citizens in our community
now
who have that kind of money just think
how great we could be if they donated
their uh
their money toward different efforts
you've got uh george soros who's uh
gives big donations to causes the bill
gates foundation bill and melinda gates
foundation warren buffett has has
promised his money to a foundation is
that not the same thing
well it's the difference in charity and
justice giving money to charity
people who are ill people are hungry
charity soup kitchens
or
this next stage would be institutional
charity you actually build a hospital
you build a library you start a high
school in the old days in my hometown by
an industrialist who who built it
and then there's the third stage that
this book is concerned about which
involves contending with abusive
concentrated power of business and
government and shifting more power to
the people so that we can have long
overdue changes living wage universal
health care
new kind of tax system
modern public transit
adequate law enforcement budgets against
corporate crime fraud and abuse imagine
250 billion dollars in computerized
billing fraud in the healthcare industry
alone according to the gao
and
experts like malcolm sparrow at harvard
university i mean just imagine the
federal trade commission peter his
annual budget
is about
270 million dollars
one
class of fraud in the healthcare
industry 10 percent of what we spend in
health care is fraud
250 billion dollars there aren't enough
federal cops on the corporate crime beat
and the corporate crime reporter
documents that every week here in
washington
from your 1986 book big boys
the philos again 1986
the philosophy guiding our political
institutions is that when times are
tough we should leave the wealthy and
powerful alone or sucker them with
fruits from the public treasury for only
they can lead the country out of the
valley of economic despair to the
hilltops of recovery
well that's sort of prophetic given the
wall street bailout no i think when
large corporations you see small cor
small businesses they have to meet the
test of the market peter and if they
don't they go bankrupt but if you're big
corporation and influential you go to
washington for bailout all kinds of
bailouts
or continuing subsidies that tax tax
credits for example
sub cash subsidies handouts giveaways to
our
you know to explo exploit our natural
resources
oil gas timber etc
so i think that's a bad lesson it's kind
of spoiling the giant
child here when they think that if they
misbehave if they
drain and loot uh
and recklessly speculate with people's
pensions and mutual funds that if
something goes wrong they can just
go down and get the taxpayer to bail him
out
uh that's called the moral hazard but
the the important thing is
if people believe in the in the free
enterprise market system they've got to
believe in the freedom to fail
now there is a strong role for
government in emergencies and so forth
but
we've got to teach big business
that their days of
looking it up at the taxpayer trough are
over and i don't see that the case i
think they they could get a repeat
performance and then they'll say hey we
got five big banks now not just 10
controlling 50 percent of the deposits
you got a bill of south washington of
course the taxpayers never asked there's
no participation there's no role we have
a constitutional oligarchy in the
country and that's bread a corporate
government corporate state some
philosophers call it but it's a
corporate government and people are just
shut out i mean what role did the people
have in military and foreign policy and
whether we go to undeclared wars
overseas and increase our national
insecurity
people are shut out and when they see it
day after day and they don't get civic
skills and civic experience in their
schools as youngsters
they they they move inward
they basically move inward on their
private lives and just try to get
through the day and poverty is
increasing so it's pretty hard to get
through the day these days
their public citizen lives are almost
zero
and she said well gee people don't turn
up they don't go to
town meetings they don't go to
neighborhoods you know
half a democracy showing up well part of
it is simply they're saying themselves
what good is it that you know the bosses
are going to do whatever they're going
to do anyway
so we have a big turnaround coming
around the more you involve people in
self-government the more you involve
them in candidacies and local
candidacies and others the more they're
going to raise their expectations get
self self-confidence become
knowledgeable be able to engage in
abstract think more abstract thinking
rather than impulsive no yes tight
bursts of frustration that we're seeing
around the country
what was your father's definition of
capitalism and do you share it yeah well
he once we he there is the socratic
method around the table they would ask
us questions and stimulate and while we
were eating and he once said
what's the difference between capitalism
and socialism well his definition was
that
socialism was government ownership of
the means of production and capitalism
was government that was corporate
ownership of the means of government
so
take your choice right concentrated
power
so what do you consider yourself
well i i like to say i consider myself a
justice seeker that leaves me open not
to prejudge not to select out evidence
because it's not reflecting my
predilections uh otherwise known as an
open mind that's why one of my favorite
authors was alfred north whitehead the
british uh mathematician philosopher who
ended his career teaching at harvard
those books by him are aims of education
for example
adventures of ideas i would urge all
college students to read
ralph nader how much
do you think you agree with pat buchanan
on issues that's a very important
question because i think we're heading
into a liberal conservative convergence
and
the faster it comes the faster we're
going to deal with problems in this
country and straighten out congress
and the state legislatures so for
example here are some convergences
real conservatives not corporatists you
know masquerading as conservatives
real conservatives do not like corporate
welfare subsidies handouts bailouts
giveaways i think a lot of progressives
don't either
real conservatives don't like an
excessive loss of sovereignty
which is world trade organization and
nafta all treaties require some
give up of sovereignty this is the
greatest loss of sovereignty in our
history
progressives and conservatives are very
very dubious about the patriot act and
be being able to go into people's homes
without warrants for 72 hours not notify
them and get their records that's why
for example bob barr former congressman
former fbi agent and i have co-signed
some letters dealing with the patriot
act liberals and conservatives also uh
have
a strong law and order component that's
not just
attached to street crime that's the
corporate crime which takes far more
lives injuries sickness property damage
and street crime just think workplace
related diseases 58 000 losses 100 000
people dying from negligence in
hospitals
65 000 people dying from air pollution
45 000 americans die every year
according to the journal of public
health peer-reviewed article by harvard
researchers because they can't afford
health insurance to get diagnosed and
treated now take all those which we
would like to see are preventable and
compare it with street homicides which
is about 15 000 a year
so the the law and order bit uh comes
very powerful from
on the big boys not just street crime
from liberals and conservatives so
pat buchanan i think is more of a
conservative than he is a corporatist
and i think there's and and the magazine
american conservative
represents that they don't like reckless
laws they like constitutional compliance
they you know if we're going to have a
war it should be declared that's what's
in the constitution
and
so i think if we get a liberal
conservative convergence it's huge look
what's going on right now
barney frank democrat ron paul
independent or republican are now
converging on beginning to cut the waste
in the military budget which was a total
taboo not even discussed in major
presidential campaigns
so that's the beginning there
so we're seeing that
beginning to emerge could be easily the
most powerful force in america
who's your favorite member of congress
well i like henry waxman uh ed markey
in the in the house in the senate i like
senator feingold
and not on all issues but and then you
don't like any of them on all issues but
they're really up there senator franken
is
i think stepping in the shoes of
senator wellstone more and more
there aren't many
left anymore
i don't think the great legislation for
consumer worker and environmentalism
that got in the in the 60s and early 70s
would ever pass today
would ever reach the floor we have a
really devastating
gridlock in congress and the filibuster
has become the graveyard of
legislation that the house passes like
food safety is still not passed
even though some food companies want it
the senate is a very very serious
pathological display
of legislative abdication and i cannot
understand why senator reid and the
democrats have not modified that
filibuster rule and ended up with a
situation as you can't pass any
legislation if you don't have 60 votes
instead of 51.
who's your favorite ceo
uh i think it's the the head of
interface corporation
uh ray anderson
uh he has turned his company into the
direction of zero pollution 100
recycling it's the biggest carpet tile
manufacturer in the country with plants
abroad when you hear him speaking and he
started this in 1994 when he heard paul
hawkins
talk about his book industrial ecology
when you see the you think you're
talking to an environmental engineer
this is a great man
and he's
cut his cost
reduced his burden on the environment
gotten tremendous gratification with his
workers
and should get more publicity on c-span
and in fact he wrote a book did he not
yes yeah and we covered it on book tv
you can uh google his name or google you
can search his name at booktv.org and
you can watch his presentation and his
talk about his book the other one is
yvonne chenard of patagonia which he
deliberately tries to keep the support
the sports
uh gear
and
he again has realized how to make the
workplace a wonderful gratifying place
to work very very ecologically oriented
these are the people really we've had a
parade of corporate criminals on tv
because of their misdeeds in the last
two years
you know but
we really have to bend
to these uh middle-sized companies uh
that are really a pioneering and
breaking ground do you think it's
important that patagonia manufacture in
the u.s
or is it okay with you if they
manufacture in china etc
well i'd like the chinese to develop
their domestic market and not suck a lot
of industry and jobs from the us
using uh uh
coarsened labor you know oppressed labor
60 cents an hour it's not a living wage
in china and then shipping back to this
country that's very very unhealthy so i
i urge all people all companies to try
uh and produce here
and if they want to invest in china for
the domestic market fine but i don't
like excessive dependency
on other countries when we can be much
more rationally self-sufficient
from your 2002 book crashing the party
you don't run for president directly you
ask the media to run you for president
or if you have the money you also pay
the media for exposure
reaching the voters relies almost
entirely on how the media chooses to
perceive you in your campaign
in short this virtual reality is the
reality
that's true uh
for example a majority of people polled
and wanted me on the presidential
debates
um they don't want to fall asleep you
know these two this is a democrat
republican
debate the questions are very
predictable they use their campaign
slogans to answer them
it's a very straight jacketed format and
why not because the debate commission is
a corporation created by the republicans
and democrats 1987 to replace the legal
women voters who used to sponsor
presidential debates and they thought
the league was too uppity
so
we're we're proposing uh and i'm saying
this for the first time that in 2012 uh
we're proposing between 20 and 25
debates starting in new england all the
way to southern california and
washington state all the way to florida
where in the late part of the summer and
early fall
people organize in every city you have
the urban league
you have the
labor unions you have the neighborhood
groups the consumer groups environmental
groups the student groups the good
government groups all collaborating to
prepare for the arrival of the
presidential nominees and they will set
the agenda the people will set the
agenda it will be broadcast throughout
the area it will focus on regional
things
no no debate will be the same as the
other debate and that will break the
debate commission's power the two-party
power
because there's no way you can reach the
american people running for president
not on the two major party tickets
without getting on that debate on those
debates which reached 50 60 million
people and i believe it was in the good
fight that you spent a lot of time
talking about the presidential debates
the commission on presidential debates
yes and that was a 2004 book
this is from civic arousal and then
we're going to get to your calls my half
hour is up
in our rigged two-party monopoly third
parties or independent candidates do not
usually win but what they do is push the
agendas bring new energies for new
leadership along yeah think the liberty
party 1840 anti-slavery first out of the
box
think the
greenback party the progressive party
the labor party the people's party the
women's right to vote parties
look at aren't we glad that some voters
decided they weren't going to go for the
least worse between the whigs and the
democrats or the democrats and
republicans put their vote on that other
column
and now it's far more difficult to get
on ballots the barriers have increased
compared to the 19th century as
thoroughly documented in my campaign
manager's book grand illusion the myth
of voter choice in a two-party tyranny
and that means that we're losing out on
new energies into the electoral arena
new ideas different kinds of background
experience different agendas and more
voter choice that's what candidate
rights mean when more candidates can get
on the ballot local state national the
voters have more of a choice
and with gerrymandered districts
sometimes they only have the incumbent
you know 90 percent of congressional
districts are slam dunk republican slam
dunk democrats that's an autocracy
that's a one-party doubt
and we've really got to wake up and say
enough is enough
it all starts with people
it all starts with people saying i'm
going to take some more time on my civic
duties civic responsibilities political
engagement i'm going to break my routine
otherwise we'll continue sliding and
sliding as our country has the top
average wage inflation adjusted was 1973
even though the economy has grown and
there's more poverty and more all the
things that shouldn't occur in this
country and that's the way it's going to
go until people say i mean something i
count for something as a citizen i'm no
longer going to walk through life saying
you can't fight city law city hall
whatever will be will be
ralph nader is our guest on in-depth
time for your phone calls emails and
tweets and we're going to start with an
email this is anthony davis who has
emailed in about 11 questions for you
but we'll just pick a couple
ralph doesn't own a car a computer has
never sent an email and has never been
in a walmart and yet seems to be in
touch with reality
how do you manage that he asks because i
don't think reality necessarily requires
to own a car or have a computer or
go to walmart it's just that simple we
need time to think for ourselves there
are all kinds of other things that we
can learn about the world we can talk
with people we can travel we can read
books
um
i mean why do we have to
follow the party line so to speak you
truly have never sent an email never
sent an email don't know
no how do you write how do you write
your books under wood typewriter when
the electricity goes out with a
thunderstorm i'm still going but that's
like what once a year
not recently
but the important thing is
is that
and this is really excuse me this is
important to talk about we need time for
reflection and contemplation if we're
dealing with 100 200 emails and we're
sending out dozens of text messages and
back and forth we're dealing with bits
bits of information some are pretty
trivial and gossipy
we have to move information connect it
to knowledge connect it to judgment and
then connect it to wisdom
and you simply can't be inundated by
communication gadgets by the way it is
much harder now to call a reporter and
get a report on the line than it was 30
40 years ago much harder you get a
voicemail
you even get a voicemail now with
reporters in the washington post they
say um i don't really check my voicemail
very often email me so now you you can't
even expect the voicemail to come
through you phone newspapers magazines
you can't get through it's
press one press two
press three so the more advanced our
communication systems are the more
wonderful they are the harder it is to
get the people
ralph nader is our guest ocala florida
veronica you're on the line thanks for
holding please go ahead with your
question
uh yes mr nader an honor to speak with
you i
am just at the point of tears almost of
what you just said i'm a licensed
marriage and family therapist by
profession retired
and i praise you and commend you for the
writing you've done with your book
especially on the sections on listening
and so on and
the things you just said about not
having so much emphasis on the
technology but trying to communicate
with people person to person
voice to voice
time is short in life right yeah we
don't have much of it and i feel so sad
that uh i see so many families hurting
without the proper support
they love one another but they have a
hard time showing it
and i think your book is a great thing
to encourage them to make those
generation generation connections
and i just want to thank you for writing
it and commend you for
all the wonderful things you said today
i
consider myself a democrat turner
conservative
but if you were running for president i
would vote for you in a heartbeat thank
you she makes a very important point of
people the people the more the filters
are technological
instead of conversations
uh within families within neighborhoods
etc
town meetings gatherings uh the less
we're going to be able to
detect our problems
develop some sort of consensus and move
towards solution
children today are technologically
saturated i mean you have 16 year olds
bragging about 400 text messages a day
what's the urgency
so they're text messaging from the
second floor of the home
down to the kitchen
so and this is just the beginning unless
we become aware what's happening to us
and what this technology is doing and
try to turn this technology to
productive uses instead of trivial uses
introverting uses gossipy uses
they're going to be a menace the
technology will be a major menace to any
kind of
turnaround in a
putative democratic society and to go
back to your 17 tradition solitude was
one of them
yes in fact now the children are so over
programmed you get a lot of professional
mothers and fathers
and they raise children and one of them
stays home usually the
the mother and over scheduling the child
enormously over scheduling the child not
not a moment
in terms of soccer and dance and music
and their courses and this and that not
a moment for the child stay alone and
our parents let us
lie on the grass and look at the stars
walk through the fields and
pick the dandelions listen to the music
of the birds
uh
i mean they had such good intuitive
judgment and many parents do if they
give themselves a chance if they don't
just conform
if they think for themselves that's what
we've got to get our children to do not
sit in front of computers day after day
think for themselves
pat red bank new jersey you're on with
ralph nader please go ahead
hi mr nader i i've read that you were
offered to be george mcgovern's vice
presidential candidate after tom
eagleton withdrew
in 1972 and i was wondering if that was
true and if so can you
talk about the circumstances thank you
he called me to ask me if i would be
considered along with other candidates
they were looking for substitute for tom
eagleton
and they wanted a group of people and i
told him i'd rather be a full-time
citizen good luck on the campaign
and that was the end of that yeah but
did it what your appetite for your four
runs
well it was not being able to get
anything done in washington
you know we people have lost control of
washington uh and everywhere you go
there are corporate lobbyists and
corporate executives and trade
associations and all over congress it's
all about money money raising money
between republicans and democrats often
with uh quid pro quo so
you have a choice peter you either
go to malibu and watch the whales
or you try to generate new political
energies
this is you know as a professor at
harvard law school richard parker
wrote a tiny little paperback called
hear the people rule about 10 years ago
and he made the case that the government
has a constitutional duty to facilitate
the political and civic energies of the
people
and that's very important that's why
eyes glaze when i'm on tv and i discuss
you know abuses of utilities for example
electric telephone
and they're all really interested in the
detail then i say by the way there is a
way to turn this around i mean what if
we had a law that required uh this to be
in your electric telephone gas bill or
in your motor vehicle department
i'll show it yeah yeah right and what if
it invited you what is this this is
called the citizen utility board idea
so you say okay these utilities they get
nice tax breaks they're monopolies what
do they do by way of reciprocity and so
in illinois and san diego
it required these utilities to put it in
their envelope
when they bill you once in a while
say twice three times a year and you
this thing would fall out
and it would say dear customer this is
not from your utility company and
ask you a number of questions are you
satisfied with this do you think this is
too high
a utility rate
are you getting through
would you like representation if you do
fill it out and
you can put send in five bucks 10 15 20
bucks you get a vote council directors
is elected they hire the economist the
lawyers the advocates the consumer
champions to represent you in 1993 this
group with 180 000 members in illinois
nonprofit group
negotiated without even suing
commonwealth edison a 1.3 billion with a
b dollar refund to northern
illinois families for overcharging them
now when you go through this first of
all it violates the sound bite rule
right peter when you look at it took me
almost a minute you know to describe it
second the eyes glaze over when you are
concentrating on
abuses there's a tension there on tv but
when you start talking about solutions
proposals ways we can
get these things done the eyes glaze
over i don't know whether this is
cultural
i don't know because it takes longer to
explain because it's something new
but we need a program in this country
for inventors
who have great ideas even though they
don't have wall street money
whether it's energy or housing or public
transit or simple things like
all over the world today
there are poor people sucking uh to try
to transfer gasoline from one container
to another and they get the stuff in
their mouth
and so
my nephew
developed for less than two dollars and
fifty cents a siphon
just two dollars and fifty cents in mass
production where never again would they
have to suck and breathe in the liquid
and the vapors it's a siphon works
perfectly simply and
you think anybody's running to his door
for his solution that's why we need an
inventor's uh program
in that way his his group's called kaura
futures spells
c-a-u-r-a futures he's trying to
preserve and protect the equatorial
forest in southern venezuela a beautiful
area the size of new hampshire and
vermont with 300 3 000 natives
you know pristine waters
and and this is what he stumbled on they
were sucking the stuff and getting it
into them and he developed a simple
gadget and is this the same nephew who's
worked on your books with you yes what's
his name uh tarek miller on he's a a phd
in
ecology and is he claire's
lara's
and once again does he have a website
uh i think it's kaura
c-a-u-r-a-futures.org probably and from
ralph nader's action for a change book
when student energy is coupled with
professional skills
major changes can be accomplished ryan
from staten island new york you're on
with ralph nader please go ahead
oh mr nader yes sir i voted for you back
in 2004 because i didn't like the skull
and bone society i know bush and kerry
are part of that and i know that you
wanted to i was going to thank you why
didn't you i would thought to merging
the reform party the green party and the
national law party to form a third party
well i've done it three times and people
either stay home out of disgust
uh with the political system you know
half the people don't vote
the the level of enemy the level of
withdrawal people call it apathy is so
enormous people now many of them don't
want to serve on juries the great
institution of our country they don't
want to go to vote because they don't
think it matters doesn't mean anything
to them and so i run now three times for
president i'm almost tempted
i'm almost tempted to write a book
which which basically says you lead i
follow
now it's up to the people
exhortation only has so
so much to go
uh they've got to generate the energy
five people here in a neighborhood ten
build up start with one start with two
uh you'll you'll be surprised how many
people agree with you how many people
want to go forward open up the whole
process give people a voice have a
democracy worthy of the name
and uh
it is interesting you know he mentioned
skull and bones when i was campaigning i
went to yale and i stood in front of
this awesomely somber building of skull
and bones which is a secret society for
yale patrician students
isn't it unbelievable
that kerry and bush of all the places
they could have gone to school of all
the places they could have gone to
fraternities but they came out of that
skull and bones it's such a symbol for
the concentration of patrician power to
build the plutocracy in the oligarchy
that now controls the country of course
it's always controlled the country all
societies have you know oligarchies but
we're supposed to be smarter than that
we're supposed to believe more in a
deliberative democracy and give people
responsibility that articulates their
energy and their expectation level
uh you say you ran for president three
times a week officially officially i was
going to say we've got you down for as
running for four times no in 1996 i
wasn't an official candidate i was asked
by david brauer the great
environmentalist if i would consent to
put my name on a california ballot and
then other states did that and so i
didn't really campaign much
jackson wyoming butch good afternoon to
you
thank you very much i voted for you mr
nader
i
you know i'm very impressed with you
i
would like you to listen to what i have
to say
and
i hope you take up this course
josh box
has a documentary called gasland
it's about the
drilling for natural gas
halliburton and
all these gas companies are putting in
530 somewhat chemicals into our water
supply
it shows in the documentary how people
are like uh turn on their forces putting
a lighter to it and the
the water is catching on fire this is
going
throughout the country you need to uh
c-span needs to get
on the bandwagon about this gasoline
movie
yeah this deals with fracturing uh for
natural guys they have
discovered a way to economically from
their point of view the companies to get
huge amounts of natural gas by
fracturing and that opens up large areas
for example in pennsylvania and upstate
new york uh to these
fracturing processes which take take a
lot of water
they are not environmentally benign
there is a denial by the companies that
they've ever contaminated
aquifer give them time uh we have to ask
ourselves why are we wasting 75 of our
energy and then messing up the whole
environment look at the
gusher and the
offshore and the gulf uh why are we
endangering the environment before we
become much more efficient
we can
cut the uh waste from our electric
utilities lighting heating air
conditioning systems engines motor
vehicles enormously according to on the
ground technology now so my first point
on energy uh is conservation
conservation conservation get more work
out of less energy get these 50 70 80
mile 90 mile per uh gallon uh
cars
on the road and the same with building
structures we're not using a fraction of
what we can use we're more efficient
than we were 30 years ago my sister just
come out with a reader laura nader
with the contributions of specialists
across the whole range economic uh uh
environmental
governmental efficiency anthropological
the whole works historical as to why
we're so stuck in fossil fuel and
nuclear and not opening up renewability
and and efficiency etc and what to do
about it you look at that list of
contributors peter you almost never see
them on national tv people like art
rosenfield who's revolutionized energy
conservation in california that's why
california is one of the most energy
efficient states they got a long way to
go too
or amory lovens
who consults with the pentagon and
utilities on efficiencies and renewables
and is against nuclear power just on
economic grounds when do you ever see
these people you see people who who
don't know much about it they happen to
be in think tanks with an extra grind
but the people who have an honest
experienced hands-on
knowledge are not getting on national tv
and that impoverishes our debates
polarizes it in a very uh
weak political polarization on capitol
hill
and
we've got to get people who know
to talk to the american people and with
the american people going back to
anthony davis's email he lives in
lakewood ohio and he said he's the one
who sent in a number of questions should
let him host this program what mistakes
has ralph made in his life that he has
learned the most from
the biggest mistake is early on
when we were getting a lot of good
legislation through that i didn't focus
on civic skills in elementary schools
to to generate the citizens of the
future because right now so much of
education peter is memorization
regurgitation vegetation and now it's
looking at screens uh computer screens
where if you connect the classroom with
the community the way a teacher in the
fifth grade in
in
salt lake city did when a girl came into
class one day and she said uh teacher i
i think that there's a waste dump
four blocks away covered with trees
and to make a long story short she
turned the teacher turned it into a
project
they met the mayor they had a news
conference they documented it was a
waste dump they got it cleaned up then
they testified for the legislature she
was so excited she writes a book called
kids and social action just printed out
in st paul minnesota which i encourage
teachers and students to read that was a
big mistake not doing that the second
one was not
developing civic skill workshops all
over the country where people go in and
they get a little uh certificate at the
end maybe six hours one hour at a time
and they'd learn some consumer skills
and where to get more information
voting skills how to be a skilled voter
you hardly ever hear those words
together right it helps to do a little
homework uh how to
mobilize and motivate people how to
defend yourself if uh your civil rights
civil liberties
that could be done all over the country
i'm still looking for an entrepreneur to
do it
similar to hr block you know they have 7
000 storefronts there should be 7 000 of
these really simple clear
motivational training
for us to be effective citizens and
voters
back to 17 traditions what is the
question that your father would ask you
when you came home from school about
learning and believing
well this was really an amazing
memorable exchange
i walked home one day i think i was 10
and my father said hi ralph i said hi
dad he said what did you learn today did
you learn how to believe
or did you learn how to think
whoa
i went to my room and
i said what's this all about well
ever since then and when i went to high
school and college and law school i
would say to the to myself is this
teacher trying to get me to believe
or trying to get me to think it's okay
to believe but
it's good good to have it
prefaced by thinking
and it's just these kinds of moments in
growing up that so many
children should treasure
there's a lot of routine in family life
and
but they should treasure those and write
them down
sean in vancouver washington you're on
with author ralph nader please go ahead
mr nader i was wondering if you might
comment on the brilliant work of derek
jensen and also mr nader
you know everyone knows that the
republicans are nothing but a bunch of
stooges for wall street but what's so
maddening and repulsive about the
democrats is it seems like they try to
come across as
wise pragmatists rather than as a
cynical opportunist
sean who is derek jensen
uh derek jensen is an environmental
activist and author um right now his
probably his most famous book is end
game
all right thank you let's get an answer
from mr nader i'm not familiar with it
i'll tell you there's so many good books
coming out this is the age of muckraking
this is the age of a golden age of
documentaries
on iran on iraq for example brilliant
documentaries eugene jiricki did some
others uh why
iraq for sale
and
who can keep up with them but it's
interesting that never in american
history have there been more exposes you
see it on 60 minutes you see it
sometimes on
public radio you see it on
books
magazines newspapers new york times
washington post and never has there been
so little effect which is a sign of the
decay
of the ability of the citizenry to take
charge
as we the people preamble in our
constitution indicates we should it's a
decay of popular sovereignty i was
talking with a person in c-span you know
very well
at brian lamb
and i said to him brian
you've performed with your staff
spectacularly in exposing how congress
operates to the american people how they
debate committees the whole works
the difference between pre-c span and
post c-span is probably a thousand-fold
greater awareness and knowledge about of
the american people about their congress
and the congress is getting worse
i would argue or some would argue that
you're not having a computer not going
online regularly
says you're missing a lot of
writing and you're missing a lot of
different websites where people are
publishing because this is yeah this is
the future that's part of it the
knowledge revolution is not for not
producing a democratic revolution
see the
we're whether we're too overwhelmed it's
too much
um
like we're you know
being stuffed with this stuff there are
great websites as you say
and
blogs there's some pretty bad ones too
but it's not working and we have to ask
why when everything is at your
fingertips
you know you may not be able to buy a
lot of books or subscribe to a lot of
magazines but on the internet you can
get huge amount of material instantly
virtually enough for nothing
and it's not changing
whether people are turning out on the
ground for town meetings for voting
for gatherings for initiatory democracy
and this this is a tremendously stunning
revelation to those who believe
that knowledge is action knowledge leads
to action
glenn freeland michigan please go ahead
um yes sir thank you and um thank you mr
nader and uh mr nader everyone knows um
about the holocaust denial
movement um the people who say the nazi
holocaust never happened
what i wanted to ask you about was
there's a similar kind of thing going on
now with global warming a lot of people
are saying global warming isn't real it
isn't happening um what can be done to
um fight this especially on a personal
level
well first of all it's undeniable that
the glaciers are beginning to melt just
go to greenland go to alaska go to
antarctica look at it on the website
the andes
this is the hottest six months in
recorded world history
june was the hottest month ever recorded
on on earth so that even rush limbo
shouldn't be able to deny that
uh he better get his anti-perspirants
out
uh the question is uh what's the cause
uh the deniers think that's just
cyclical that this happens every
thousands of years
and uh don't worry about it well it's
coming on much faster than cyclical
theory would have us believe
just in the last 10 years
all these changes are stunning people
uh and it's occurring in our oceans it's
affecting our forests as well the amazon
now is getting less water and that that
could have devastating consequences
so the the argument of most scientists
climatologists are is
that this is caused by a release of
greenhouse gases
methane being one of the worst but the
one that gets the most publicity is
carbon dioxide this comes heavily from
our use of fossil fuels and
other sources that are man-made
uh so what do the deniers say about that
well they say
uh well you know there's no real proof
of that and besides more common carbon
dioxide's good it's going to create more
plants i mean some people will get less
rain in some areas but generally
speaking it'll spread out
i never thought that we would have this
kind of medievalism in our scientific
debates and the reason why it plays in
some quarters in congress is because
newt gingrich in 1995
led the abolition of the office of
technology assessment glenn which is a
20 million dollar
advisory unit independent nonpartisan to
congress that could debunk some of this
nonsense and they could give good advice
whether it's on genetic engineering or
privacy technology intrusion or nuclear
power or any other thing in fact they
came out with a report warning about the
risks of offshore drilling in deep
waters many years ago so now we're
trying to get this reinstated
so that at least if some crazy
assertions are made that are simply not
substantially documented on capitol hill
they will have an independent arm their
own arm
to say in a very polite way it just
isn't so
michael oreskis in 04 four
reviewed your books the good fight and
in pursuit of justice and this goes back
to civic participation and he wrote
power of corporations is an effect of
declining civic participation not its
cause but subtlety is not nader's strong
suit
well you know you can say it's cause or
effect or both
when you have a lot of corporate power
blocking people out just think what
happens in the workplace in america for
example and not just in the coal mines
and elsewhere
the the intimidation the fear it can be
very subtle but people begin censoring
themselves they become fearful anxious
about their jobs etc
are they going to go after work and
challenge some policy to in the in the
city or a town that the company doesn't
like so that could be a cause then after
a while if people just do not challenge
corporate power do not say look you're
an artificial entity corporation the
word corporation doesn't exist in our
constitution nor does political party
why are we ruled by both of you
we should rule the people should rule
through intermediate institutions and
direct democracy like initiative
referendum or recall
if people back off and they don't
challenge them in these outrages even
when they're shredded in terms of their
pensions and savings and they're
defrauded
then that simply is another
encouragement of corporations to push
the envelope more and more
adam climber his review of the ralph
nader reader in 2000
in an odd way the ralph nader reader
shows that nader is part of an old
political stream if not a mainstream
when he dismisses his opponents as a
political duopoly the dem rep party he
employs the traditional exaggeration of
third-party candidates
well i think if you look at all these
books they're mostly understatements of
what the real condition turned out to be
or was at the time uh the books uh the
unsafe and new speed
i mean it's such an understatement of
how much the auto company suppressed and
all the different hazards so we're not
in the in the business of exaggeration
you don't get through the press if you
exaggerate too much
you may have one
potential but you got to be as accurate
as as possible
the the second thing that's really
important is that
in many ways
the third parties are espousing
majoritarian positions
not the two major parties for example we
came out with a specific corporate crime
enforcement crackdown
obama and uh and bush and uh
mccain never never had a corporate crime
we came out for a living wage at least
equal and inflation adjusted to 1968
which would be ten dollars an hour
instead of seven dollars and 25 cents
twice the productivity and the workers
are making less in real terms that was
that's a majoritarian position we came
out with uh severe criticism of the tax
system uh in the corporate tax havens
and all the rest that's a majoritarian
position we came out for single-payer
you can look at single-payer action.org
for more details come out for
single-payer that is a majoritarian
position in the polls you know full
medicare for all among doctors 59
percent in nepal and among nurses
so where do they get off saying just
because we're minor parties excluded
from the debates excluded from
recognition uh for the validity of our
experience and our arguments and
documentation by the mainstream press
that we're exaggerating
next call for ralph nader santa cruz
california jeffrey good afternoon hey mr
neither yes jeffrey hi i just want to
say thank you so much for everything
that you have done and you are a great
hero to me and many many others and i
just want to say thank you for that
all the work that you've done for so
many um i have a bunch of questions here
and i know i can't ask you all of them
but one of them was what do you think
about the recent supreme court decision
on unlimited donations to um
you know people who are running for
office from i guess you know either side
further it was a 5-4 decision by the way
further commercializing our election
process at the local state and national
level now corporations directly they
don't have to set up pacs they can
directly as long as they're independent
of the candidates go after
or support any candidate they want with
unlimited money
now you know the congressional
presidential elections of 2008 they they
spent about five billion dollars i mean
exxon made about 50 billion dollars last
year one company exxon mobil
so
it's opening the gates uh to
the subordination of civic values the
access to justice
health safety advances
uh a break for the working person all
these civic values are being
subordinated by commercial
values commercial imperatives uh
commercial commands
and i i really was very disappointed
even knowing how
corporatist those five justices are i
was very disappointed a in their
reasoning and b i was disappointed in
the minimal sense of significance that
they have historically in this country
to be the sentinels for
democratic uh societies uh initiatives
and the ability of people to have a
voice on the merits not on the money
that's the difference we should have
elections that are based on the merits
not on the money
much of your writing in many of your
books many of the emails we've received
many of the tweets we've re received all
come to this one right here and i want
to read this tweet and we'll have you
answer it mr nader i am a fan but will
you concede that most of your florida
voters in 2000 would have gone to gore
here we go again let's start with this
gore won the popular vote only the
antiquated electoral college allowed the
man who came in second to become
president most countries you know if you
get the most votes you went in florida
250 000 democrats moved across the
island voted for george w bush
the spread between bush and gore is
about 527 votes but the recount
was leaning toward bush
toward gore in terms of a full state
recount ordered by the florida supreme
court but it was over it was blocked by
the 5-4 political decision of the u.s
supreme court the democratic exit polls
had our vote the green party vote uh
39 of our vote would have voted for gore
25 would have voted for bush the rest
would have stayed home
every third party in florida had more
votes every more liberal progressive
third party had more votes than the
difference between bush and gore
people who focus on this in florida
they don't want to pay attention to pat
buchanan took a lot of votes quote took
a lot of votes from george w bush in
florida that's okay on their side
here's my approach peter let's get over
this
as long as we admit
that we all have an equal right to run
for election we should not engage in
this political bigotry that focuses on a
third party green party
as as as taking away votes from gore
when clearly george w bush took far more
votes away from court didn't he but why
not call him a spoiler because this
political bigotry thinks that third
parties are second-class citizens they
don't have equality
and that's what we're trying to turn
around the mother of all ascent in our
country's history started with dissent
1776 for example
bob high point california you're on with
ralph nader
thank you for uh having me on i really
appreciate it and uh
i'm glad you just read that tweet i i
agree that mr nader
you had every uh right to run pat
buchanan had every right to run
but but it's really difficult when you
give those
percentages what you just did 35 25
the reality is that al gore would have
won in 2000 had you not run and all the
good work you've done i respect that but
look at what where this country went to
after george bush was elected we can't
play in the electoral college because
that was in place
you know yeah it's a very difficult
thing to to to look at and not
take a look at you mr buchanan and the
system
as uh what helped cause george bush's
election well let me let me explain that
for example um
why are you relieving uh gore of the
responsibility of winning his home state
of tennessee
or clinton arkansas
um why
are you relieving catherine harris the
secretary of state
that
hired a consulting firm to
disenfranchise thousands of people
because they had similar names to
ex-felons who can't vote in florida
or the butterfly ballot in other words
why are you picking one variable and now
let me respond to you squarely that
social scientists who studied the
elections in 200 2000
have concluded
that by pushing gore before the election
to take more progressive stands
he actually gained more votes than he
would have gotten uh
with me being in the election an
immediate ap poll right after the
election between gore and bush had bush
winning
the important thing is not the election
day tally it's the dynamics before the
weeks and months before
when gore made speeches against the big
drug companies insurance companies oil
companies his polls would go up
and he was pushed to do that because he
wanted to marginalize our vote you see
the complexities
so
don't don't hone in
on this this unwittingly politically
bigoted approach
everyone has an equal right to run
and the dynamics are so complex
before the election
that if you want to try to parse them
state after state be my guest far better
for us to focus on deliberating the
directions of our country getting more
people out to vote
uh if you ask al gore about 2000 he
doesn't blame the green party he knows
why he lost he thinks it was stolen from
him in florida he thinks he should have
gotten tennessee
of all the people who complain peter
he's the one who doesn't complain
because he knows what the dynamics were
he knows how many variables are involved
back to anthony davis's email
what are some of ralph's guilty
pleasures in life
[Laughter]
well
i've learned to minimize them in order
to focus on what i think is important
and
so if you want to know i don't drink i
do not smoke i do not have these other
addictions
i suppose the guiltiest i am is i pile
up a lot of books and paper and
newspapers
sometimes i fall behind
and uh it gets to be a little bit of a
mess
you're known in washington as a very
private person why
because most of my life my life is
public there's not much left
so that that's is that important is it
important to you
to have a slice of yes real privacy i
mean the privacy the self you know is a
constitutional right and judicially
determined
going back to brandeis law review
article in 1890 so no it is very
important to do that i think i think the
young have lost any sense of privacy
with the internet these days in their
own facebook
i mean what are they going to say to
their grandchildren
who are perched at 8 9 and 10 on their
knees years from now
and they've just come to realization
that the world is falling apart and they
say grandma and grandpa
what were you doing
when this was all
happening what were you doing what is
this generation going to say to him well
child
i was actually busy
updating my profile on facebook
you know so
they don't have a sense of privacy
and i suppose i'll leave it to the
psychologist to figure out the
consequences of that for their own
personality their own development their
own sense of
initiative
in controversial situations as citizens
uh their own
level of reflection and abstraction
but no i i i don't have much of a zone
of privacy and when you run for office
you have even less of course
albert in lancaster pennsylvania you're
on with ralph nader
hello mr nader it's always a breath of
fresh air to hear your voice
my name well i'm 23 years old and i'm
very nervous but it's always an honor to
listen to you speak
and i just want to say
your book the 17 traditions i believe
yes
yes i just think every single one of
them are very honorable
and i think it's very important what
people don't do anymore is to question
authority
and to
to listen it's very important to listen
you know there's two different kind of
people in this world those
who
wait for their turn to speak and then
there's those who are the listeners and
i'm a bit i'm a listener
and i think that's very important to
communicate because without
communication communication there's fear
you hit that you albert you hit a very
important point when you said by what
authority and questioning authority
reporters in washington almost never say
to cabinet secretaries or presidents
after they listen to their decisions by
what authority are you going to war
without declaration by what authority
secretary of state clinton you went to
pakistan and said you're going to give
them 500 million bucks i thought
congress had that appropriation
authority you might have mentioned that
you're going to recommend to congress
and the same thing with corporations
there used to be a doctrine quo orrento
so when corporations were chartered for
a certain purpose peter they they would
go beyond their purpose they would do
things in the economy beyond their
chartered purpose
and you could bring a lawsuit by what
authority is this company doing this we
have got to begin asking our rulers
political and corporate by what
authority because
the rule of law is being
pulverized the constitutional rule of
law the statutory rule of law
regulations treaties we initiated all
were violated by bush's criminal wars in
iraq and expanding it in
afghanistan apart from just
chasing after the backers of the
attackers of 9 11.
and so
year after year
these corporations and these politicians
are operating above and beyond the law
pretty soon
how's that going to affect people's own
sense of the law as it relates to
themselves
so
you keep using that question you have to
say by what authority and you will watch
how they
get marbles in their mouths trying to
answer it
if you had been president during 9 11
how would you have proceeded i would
have sent a a multinational force of
commandos
linguistic specialists cultural
specialists
to chase
the to go after the backers of the
attackers
assuming the backers were
believed to be in those mountains i
would not have blown apart the country
of afghanistan which is already riven by
tribal
fights and gotten into a quagmire which
is nine years now it's the longest war
in american history and all that's
happening is that the taliban who never
had any designs on the us
the taliban are coming back they control
over 30 percent of the area there's
about up to 30 000 of them all they have
are older rifles and rocket-propelled
grenades and some suicide
belts against the most modern army in
the history of the world helicopter
gunships drones destroyers aircraft
carriers artillery
night vision
and they're holding down the most
powerful army in the world
now there's something wrong with that
there's something wrong about why even
though they're brutal in their own way
they have the cause of causes which is
get rid of the invader and as long as
we're occupying and we're invading their
country they will have more and more
sway against a central government that
is neither central nor governmental and
it's riven with its own graft and
corruption you know it's really strange
we send truckloads of hundred dollar
bills over there to pass out to get our
way
and we accuse the central government of
corruption
i mean what we're doing is we're bribing
our way in trying to get a leeway into
this village or trying to get our trucks
through a pass
the money is often going to the taliban
we build an electric plant
that provides electricity to an area in
kandahar that's a taliban control
and they're collecting the monthly
payments
and they're using the money against us
three billion dollars in cash swoops out
of the
airport in kabul nobody knows what it is
billions of u.s tax dollars are going in
undocumented
this is a war we can't win
this is a war
that we have to have a intensive
congressional and civic discussion on
congress has turned itself into an
inkblot as bruce fine has pointed out
it's an ink block
it does nothing but want to
abandon its constitutional
responsibilities in foreign and military
policy other than to give it to the
president and rubber stamp the president
john in oceanside california good
afternoon good morning to you uh
greetings uh mr nader um what are your
impressions of the cap and trade
legislation and do you believe it's just
another excuse made legal for big
corporations to go on polluting and pass
those carbon credit swaps uh on to the
american people the uh the corporatism
of congress uh cap and trade i don't
believe it's going to work it's too
complex there are too many determinants
too many variables uh difficulties in
measurement just think of all the
pollution emissions
uh and with the offsets being able to be
set up anywhere around the world
watch that one in terms of oh we set up
a hundred thousand acres of trees here
and
in some remote area and that's an offset
so we can pollute more there i think
it's fundamentally immoral too if you
happen to be next to a polluting source
where the company got
traded off for more pollution permits i
favor a simple carbon tax you want to
increase the price of carbon in order to
facilitate
energy efficiency and renewable which i
think
energy efficiency doesn't need a carbon
tax it's the most efficient return on
investment of any energy policy but a
carbon tax is the simplest form
al gore was for a carbon tax exxon is
for carbon taxes if we're going to be
taxed we might as well be attacked in a
very clear and measurable uh manner
next call for ralph nader comes from
peytonsville ohio roger
i probably made it on yeah even though
we're political opposites there are some
things i agree with you
except when you run for political office
i
hope that's been
i hope that's because you've been
replaced by your evil twin brother uh
darth vader who
uh your evil twin brother darth nader he
was making a joke oh okay anywho but uh
what bothers me is your uh your run for
president on the green party in 2000
i printed the uh the program out so i or
the platform out so i know what's in it
uh there's
a lot of there's a lot of stuff that
sounds good like a 12 15 hour minimum
wage free child care free tuition
uh there's some stuff that sounds
debatable uh like a 75
percent uh
cut in military spending in two years
or a 100 percent tax if you make more
than 12 million dollars a year
and there's some stuff that to me sounds
rather dangerous all right uh roger
what's your point what's your question
uh
well
uh
well let me uh well at
the thing i was gonna say though is is
the the thing that sounds bad
is uh he's gotta break up things and uh
what sounds to me like a a complete
government taker over of the economy not
at all just look at
us
self-government
is rarely discussed these days
no society exists without some form of
government it can be of course cruel
wasteful government that cheapens the
character of its own people by blocking
them and turning them into obedient
surfs
or it can be a government that reflects
the total productivity of the economy
which comes back to the workers not just
in salary and wages but in common
services
in 1945 western europe was devastated
and destroyed we were number one in the
world as the most powerful force
in 1945 starting in 4647
the people of western europe through
their trade unions their cooperatives
their multi-party system
demanded and received full universal
health care day care
four week minimum paid vacation for all
the people decent labor laws good public
transit
tuition free education
family sick leave
why why could they do it and we didn't
because they just had a multi-party
system they were coming up from
destitution devastation so they could
start in a way new and fresh and they
weren't
channeled so much
to this day we don't have for all our
people what i just mentioned
now that's nothing but getting paid for
your work only through a community
process in addition to your
weekly or bi-monthly check
and they also had better pensions
and
we have productivity but it's being
sucked up
so that the few
dominate the many economically as well
as politically the top one percent of
the richest people in this country have
financial wealth equivalent to the
bottom combined 95 percent who can
justify that look how hard those 95
percent work
and they all together they're equal to
the top one percent
i believe in devolving power as well
that's why i believe in initiative
referendum recall clean elections access
to
common property you know the politicians
never discuss the commonwealth the
public lands and the public airways and
trillions of dollars of research and
development that the people pay for
why aren't they receiving some of the
benefits why don't they have more
decision power over the disposal of
these common assets why don't we have
our own radio and tv stations and
networks we're the landlords the radio
and tv stations are the tenants they
don't pay any rent they use it free and
decide who says what and who doesn't 24
hours a day
who what conservative what liberal uh
can support that kind of shutout system
so i don't think i i had a one percent
100 percent tax by the way and the the
military budget this is before 9 11.
this is during a
post-soviet union collapse the military
budget is huge waste and huge redundancy
why are we spending 80 billion of your
taxpayer dollars to keep our troops or
our soldiers
in western europe and east asia 65 years
after world war ii
defending
japan
korea
germany england italy france the
netherlands sweden from whole
moldovia
ukraine belarusa
inner mongolia
we want to be the world's police
the less we become a humanitarian
pragmatic superpower the more we have to
become
a military superpower you know what
happens to empires who emphasize that
aspect of their society they decay
is there another run for president in
you
i wish someone else would run on a
progressive agenda if i've done it three
times
uh i think the voters need that choice
otherwise they'll forget about all the
things that they've benefited from from
progressive policies back 100 years
who is that person well i think there
could be many i think bill grider a very
very good writer thinker i mean why
don't we go outside the norm here jim
hightower who was elected secretary of
agriculture in texas
these are people who uh who feel for the
people with credibility knowledge
historical contemporary um and uh given
what goes for politicians these days i
think we've got a lot of good people who
could run for president most people
don't know their names so they're never
discussed celebrity time is you know
dominant well that wasn't a yes or no
are you going to run for president i
haven't decided yet on that basis i'd
like to see someone else
do it
when i do it i go into 50 states we have
all kinds of lawsuits blocking us from
getting on the ballot that kind of
political
bigotry and anti-civil libertarian
policies of the two-party system
and you have to spend until labor day
just trying to get on the ballot you
can't get on the national debates which
is the only way to reach as i said tens
of millions of people
so we're going to try a new debate
strategy and we're going to encourage
more people to run at the local state
and national level you know if you're
not willing to lose you're never going
to win from ralph nader's book crashing
the party first stage goals for a better
america enact laws that mandate publicly
finance public elections
enact living wage laws issue
environmental protection standards
provide full medicare coverage for
everyone launch a national mission to
abolish poverty create a national
security policy to counter violence and
global diseases
renegotiate nafta and gat end criminal
justice discrimination
defend and strengthen the civil justice
system and strengthen investor
shareholder rights did we not launch a
national war on poverty in the 60s
we did and
started making gains and then it hit the
whole vietnam war inflation aftermath
and it was pretty much abandoned
i think the best way to deal with
poverty among other things is public
works that that's a very decentralized
jobs program it's real things real
buildings real clinics real mass transit
real
libraries real
uh roads and bridges
energy conservation is a great job
producer as well but we're getting away
from that and
it's amazing what roosevelt did with the
fraction of the money in the wpa and ccc
and we still see the things in our
national forests
that that benefit us from that kind of
labor
falls new jersey stand thanks for
holding your honor with ralph nader
yes good afternoon peter good afternoon
mr nader i have a question to ask you
regarding the
racial and ethnic influence of the vote
in america rather than just the
corporate aspect and
the environment
it seems to me whenever i watch cnn
especially that uh political pundits
characterize
the supreme court and congress
as being populated by insensitive old
white guys
and in light of that definition i'm just
wondering if a candidate such as
yourself
thinks he can attract the hispanic vote
and do you think
if the
the arizona law goes to the supreme
court someone like sotomayor would uh
support the law
i don't know how to pre-judge the
supreme court on this because you don't
know exactly how it would what issues it
would reach the supreme court on
that's one the second is
uh when i go around the country
campaigning or with my civic projects
i see human beings
i doubt that there are many people in
this country
uh who can relate to people as super
as human beings as i can
because what we deal with we deal with
health and safety we deal with
environmental exposure we deal with a
decent wage you don't have to
differentiate people
on those bases when you deal with civil
rights civil liberties you do because
people of color
often take the brunt
of that process
but to the extent we can deal with
people as people
uh you get a greater unification of
cause
and in support for important
redirections in our country
it is true a lot of the think tanks in
town
and the talk show host you have hannity
glenn back
limbo they do come from a common
background don't they
uh i have challenged
hannity and limbo
and back to debates because i think
they're cowardly soliloquy oriented
people they cannot stand debates they
only can constant controlling that mic
and turning it off if they don't get the
right question and i think we ought to
measure them by the standards of whether
they are cowards where they're willing
to allow their beliefs to be tested in
the crucible of extended debate perhaps
at the national press club
where where the debates often occur but
not the most controversial ones
important ones
this is c-span's book tv and you're
watching our monthly in-depth call-in
program this month it's author ralph
nader the author
or co-author of about 20 books or so it
all began in 1965 with unsafe at any
speed his latest is 2009's only the
super rich can save us ralph nader if
you were to recommend one of your books
for people to read
which one would it be for young people
civic arousal which is 56 pages
uh because they're in their 20s they
want to know
how what's what can they do you know
where is this world going
for other people i would recommend only
the super rich can save us which is in
quotes it's a work of political fiction
but it basically asks the question what
if
a handful
of the thousands of super rich in this
country in advanced age 70s 80s 90s
enlightened background
decided to back the people with their
influence their rolodex their money
and search out the leaders from
neighborhoods all the way up to the
national level
and develop a clean elections party and
develop a sub-economy of sustainable
industry and and develop congress watch
locals and develop entire media
responsive to serious issues well when
you have people like warren buffett and
barry diller and ted turner and yoko ono
and and
paul newman and others who were in this
meeting in maui at a hotel in
in hawaii in january 2006
enormous change long overdue
not disruptive of normal routines can
happen in this country
and so i put it all together
i want people to write
fiction like this very few people can
write novels
they can try
but from their own experience when
they're up against city hall or up
against some waste dump or some
educational system that's brittle with
bureaucracy
and they can't get anywhere
how do they recharge themselves by
asking the question what if
what if there are more organizers what
if we had better strategies what if
there is more money what if there is
more
media on the evening news which is a
farce now
in terms of not paying attention to
local issues the evening tv news
their imagination goes up they become
recharged
they begin less inhibited in asking rich
people in their community for money
for justice not just for charity so in
that way i think it's the most important
it's going to be a movie i hope someday
and uh warren beatty is in the book
running against schwarzenegger for
governor that's quite a campaign in
2006.
but i hope more people will do writing
like that
give themselves a chance even if they
don't think they're writers
here's a look at some of ralph nader's
favorite things and influences
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
my
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
author ralph nader under your influences
you list jesus teaching in 17th in your
17 traditions uh your childhood memoir
you talk about your christian upbringing
are you still a christian
yes i was born a christian and
i i believe very much in the golden rule
i think that
is one of the greatest concise phrases
is how people should relate to people
you also talk about confucius wisdom
confucius was you know the ultimate
concise
uh purveyor of wisdom and i as a child
actually when i was about eight nine
years old they had a confucius for
children
and i remember once he said uh how
important it is to fr to find the right
word
uh and
we we are in a uh a linguistic uh
uh period in our history where
we often have the wrong words we clutter
the words and
uh you know we have euphemisms that uh
that operate and so that that was one of
the lessons from uh uh from uh confucius
under your favorite books you told us
that eben khaldoon was one of your
favorite uh authors
i'll let you say it yes he he was a
north african
historian and he uh a remarkable mind uh
arnold toynbee
attributed to his writings
some of the greatest ideas of that
arnold toynbee wrote about
he was basically the composite mind of
that day he wrote something called the
al al-makhadama
in
1377. which is the means the preface to
a world history and there was nothing
beyond his grasp science chemistry
history sociology what we call today
sociology uh biology plant life
anthropology economics he was the one by
the way who who said that if you lower
taxes you'll increase revenue which
arthur laffer took without attribution
and put on his napkin
though but it is amazing sitting and he
was also a government servant he was a
civil servant
for many years
just imagine sitting in in some place in
north africa and having that enormous
grasp to synthesize and illuminate the
experience of centuries past just uh
it's just such a testament to the human
mind how are you exposed to evan caldoon
well when i was in princeton i majored
in oriental studies and uh that's when i
came
upon him and he he didn't finish his
huge
series but he wrote a lot of other uh
tracks and treatises unfortunately they
survived
the mongols didn't reach north africa as
they did
the libraries in alexandria and baghdad
when you were growing up would you want
to be
well i i wanted to be a lawyer fighting
for justice because we had the county
courthouse was on main street
uh right down from my dad's restaurant
and once in a while he'd take me down
and i'd sit and i watched the juries and
the lawyers go at it and the judge
and my father always wanted to be a
lawyer himself if he had the chance so
we looked at lawyers as someone fighting
for justice not the way the image of too
many lawyers is today you've written a
book about lawyers in fact yes what is
it
well it's actually written a a a lot of
books with wesley smith no content yes
no contest is on corporate lawyers
and uh we believe they are the brokers
and the architects for a lot of mischief
that corporations engage in when the
corporations want to do something that's
on the edge or over the edge they go to
the lawyers and say
show us how to do it whether it's taxes
or whether
dealing with bailouts or whatever so i
thought we should put some
responsibility on their shoulders and
not call them white shoe firms or
prestigious law firm this and that well
it it's uh interesting you uh profile
two lawyers in there lloyd cutler
and kenneth starr
yes well this was written in the mid 90s
yeah lloyd cutler was written by mark
green uh more extensively he was one of
our colleagues
in a prior book but
yeah i mean lloyd cutler was the the
master of the uh corporate government
shuttle and he'd become an advisor to
presidents then he go back to his law
firm and of course his prestige would
get more clients and
i thought he was the archetype
of of the corporate lawyer and
they operate very much in the shadows
and they shouldn't because they are real
brokers of concentrated power
to the disadvantage of consumers and
small taxpayers and workers
ken starr was
interesting in the sense
that the press kept calling him judge
star when he retired from the bench and
he was a prosecutor against clinton in
the lewinsky case
i spoke to
ted koppel once and i said you had him
on the program nightline ted you keep
referring to him as judge starr and most
people would say wow that this is an
impartial person but he was not he was
ex-judge a star
that's again what confucius says it's
the words
and our final question from anthony
davis emailed question from anthony
davis of lakewood ohio
speaking of lawyers uh what are your
thoughts on the collapse of john edwards
personal and political life you had made
positive comments about his platform and
campaign against poverty and other
issues ignored by other candidates well
i think it shows that heraclitus the
ancient greek philosopher
was right when he said character is
destiny
and i added personality is decisive
and
john edwards failed both tests
unfortunately
202 is the area code if you want to talk
with author ralph nader
737-01 for those of you in the east and
central time zones
202-737-002 for the mountain and pacific
time zones book tv at cspan.org is our
email address and if you want to send a
tweet twitter.com
booktv longview texas diana you're on
yes thank you for having me mr nader i
do hope you run for president uh you'll
have my vote that's for sure
i have two young sons and they're in
their early 30s and last night i spent
about two hours on the phone with one of
my sons who just moved to new york
connecticut area
and he is in both sons are so
uh disgruntled and disappointed with our
government but
like you said there's just so much
apathy and they feel like uh like you've
expressed that what's the use we don't
have any say
but when you talked about
citizenship
certified certificates
you know that just sprung up in me like
that that is an answer you know a
solution to maybe
a big problem that we have and i was
wondering if you could tell me how to
maybe implement that
uh even
starting
now i mean i've gone to walmart and told
the people to go to the meetings and and
tell them what the government is trying
to do and this and that but you know i
feel it's just an individual um
retired
uh there's something in some
time that i have that this seems like a
great solution good point well find a
storefront in longview texas
and
we'll try to find some people in around
there
who will give these seminars
and give the certificates on how to be a
more skilled citizen a more skilled
consumer
and know as know your rights as voters
the ballot access barriers in texas are
overwhelmingly restrictive to anybody
but the democratic or republican
nominees um as far as your sons being
discouraged and upset of course they're
not alone are they especially in that
generation i think a knowledge of
successful breakthroughs in recent
history would help i started out against
the tobacco industry and tried to get
non-smoking and airplanes buses and
trains and people thought that's crazy
that'll never happen the tobacco
industry is on its heels it's about to
be regulated in terms of its contents
it's lost ground in congress the number
of smokers have gone from 44
in 1964 of adult smoking to just about
20 percent now
it's a tremendous victory and it started
because a handful of citizens and
doctors and public health specialists
didn't say ring their hands say oh the
tobacco industry is too powerful they
went and they built it one by one ten by
ten a hundred by a hundred the same is
true for the disarmament of uh
hundreds of nuclear warheads in
russia and the u.s we have russians here
americans over there supervising
the
reduction of the nuclear warheads which
were aimed at one another
and could destroy one another's country
in 30 minutes
that was also uh unsuperable impossible
people marched in washington they
marched around the country many of them
looked well-dressed and republicans and
reagan took note of that again
it's people doing their part
americans have less lead in their in
their blood now because a number of
people
decided to push for legislation to ban
lead in gasoline
so you don't buy leaded gasoline anymore
it's unleaded again it was considered
impossible abolishing asbestos the
scourge of lung cancer and mesothelioma
again started with a number of people i
don't think young people today are given
civic history they're given the history
of wars and elections and opening up the
west and etc they need to be given civic
history of people who broke through
because they had enough self-respect as
citizens and self-confidence to lock
arms with other citizens in order to
improve our society for future
generations as well as themselves well
andy cagle emails in do you think a
lawsuit similar to the tobacco lawsuits
accusing an arrangement of oil gas and
coal companies with criminal negligence
or public nuisance is an appropriate
measure of decarbonizing of our energy
supply well yes i mean there are tort
lawsuits against the contamination of
water and harming people's health
that have been brought over the years
it's not likely you can bring a class
action
given the standards for class actions
but there needs to be
far more
of these kinds of litigations this idea
that we're litigation crazy societies is
factually totally false we filed more
lawsuits in 1840 per capita
individual lawsuits against individuals
than we do today per capita
it's very expensive and very hard to
file these lawsuits and 90 percent of
all wrongful injuries in this country
the the victims never even go to a
lawyer
whether they're hospital negligence law
firms or toxic exposure or latent
defects and products they buy
um the the fact is we don't use the
courts enough and the court budgets are
ridiculously small most people will be
stunned to know that the court budget in
your state
is less than two percent
of the total budget of your state
government
and your prison budget is anywhere from
three to five times more than it is
filled with often with many non-violent
uh inmates in no contest you talk about
splat lawsuits is that am i getting that
right the uh
public uh nuisance lawsuits is it splash
slap slap yeah slap that's it these are
lawsuits say you got a developer in your
community and he's going overboard and
you don't want this particular area or
land or garden or whatever and you go to
a town meeting you speak against it
they will often
file a lawsuit to shut you up and of
course they never win those lawsuits but
the person says oh look i'm being sued i
can't afford a lawyer uh i'll have to
shut up
and that's why they're called strategic
law
slap is a acronym anyway but they are
now being rolled back because some
people are counter-suing and
straightening out these people it's
basically a lawsuit against free speech
this tweet comes in from ken
have you and michael moore ever
collaborated if not your opinion about
michael moore
well he he was in our office i mean he
came out of our office after he left the
editorship of mother jones and he did
roger and me with the
head of general motors and now he broke
new ground in documentaries
and helped
launch the golden age of documentaries
i haven't had much connection with him
recently he doesn't look backward he
doesn't return calls and he
has turned against us during the 2004
campaign after going all over the
country with us in 2000 at huge rallies
madison square garden and boston garden
at target center
so
i don't quite know where he is at any
given time politically
next call for ralph nader is from
arlington washington bob go ahead
yeah hi um mr nader
thank you for
all of years of public service uh say
since the uh fourth estate in this
country
is really shrinking and of course it's
lacking
and
the lack of investigative journalism
that's going on it seems like wikipedia
has become our major news source i
wanted to ask your opinion on that and i
also wanted to ask your opinion mr nader
on this um
this so-called deficit commission that's
going to go after the entitlements like
social security
and medicare and it wouldn't it be a
shame if under the leadership of a
democratic president uh
we attacked
the uh last remnants of the new deal on
the great society thanks again mr nader
yes well on wikipedia i i don't use
wikipedia but
it seems to be used a great deal and its
errors are corrected rather quickly by
people who who do use it
that's one
i think the laying off of a lot of
reporters at dalys around the country
obviously does reduce the amount of
space and time devoted to what's going
on in city hall and and
the marketplace etc
and
i don't think the the blogs and websites
make up for that uh third on
uh the uh
the deficit commission i think
was tilted into a very anti-people
commission you uh erskine bowles as a
democrat
rather rather to the right of center as
it goes
uh he was with uh clinton's white house
and uh
former senator alan simpson clearly a
hard-bound but humorous republican
uh i'm i'm a little troubled by the use
of the word entitlements you notice how
the use of word entitlements is social
security and medicare but not to
corporate welfare which is huge hundreds
of billions of dollars of corporate
welfare every year
that's you the word that's used is
incentives
so when you when you give welfare to
corporations it's incentives but when
you recycle people's taxes back in
medicare and social security that's an
entitlement see the misuse of language
it's like we use the words detainees
because the government wants us to use
the word detainees instead of prisoners
who've been in jail for seven years
sometimes without charges
so i'm very wary i think people should
contact the commission it's going to
have hearings
and it probably has a blog
or a website and tell them what you
think they're up to
social security is rock solid until 2042
every dollar will be paid out the
problem is the government has spent the
surplus so basically social security
will have a claim on the government's
bonds medicare is being ripped off like
crazy hundreds of billions of dollars of
fraud and it needs to have an
enforcement budget correlative with the
need for prosecution
you know our enforcement budget against
corporate crime waste and fraud
is
one-tenth of one percent of the
estimated fraud and experts in this area
say that if you don't have one dollar on
enforcement for every hundred dollars of
fraud and corporate crime you can't
begin to roll it back and what's
interesting is for every dollar of a
prosecutors
for prosecutors and attorneys in the
justice department and investigators
they get 17 dollars back in rolling back
medicare fraud
so why aren't we doing this why isn't
this a campaign issue among the two
parties why don't we have debates on
this to
around the country and the missile
defense is nine billion dollars there
the american society of physicists has
said on more than one occasion it's
unworkable it's too easily decoyed why
are we spending nine billion dollars
almost what the environmental protection
agency spends on an unworkable
technology to make raytheon and boeing
and lockheed martin richer well there's
an mit professor his name is ted posto
he's willing to debate anybody
uh on missile defense nobody will debate
him
amy lovelands will debate anybody on
nuclear power they won't debate him
there there are these great
knowledgeable people who basically
cannot communicate because they can't
get on the media
and they can't get debate so i'm going
to propose to the national press club a
whole series of very powerful debates
there's a big taboo on drug policy
they want to talk about the two parties
so they fill our prisons and mexico's
blown apart in our streets and drive-by
shootings and
and huge amount of taxpayer dollars and
we don't even debate the change that's
necessary why not have kevin zees who's
written the legal encyclopedia on drug
law debate someone who thinks we should
keep the status quo
there's so many taboos peter there's so
much self-censorship
by good people in this country
and we've got to open it up and open it
up
from civic arousal who is erica mcvoy of
tallahassee florida
she was a waitress in a restaurant
in her 20s and she wrote me a remarkable
letter
uh that basically said uh
she analyzed me and and uh and my
campaign and
and mused about politics and will they
ever respond to people like us
and i i put it in this little book civic
arousal along with another letter by a
civil uh like an engineering graduate in
princeton
and i answered them and i sort of
represented their letters as the cry
of people in their 20s who often are
still looking to find themselves
have no declared public philosophy
and sometimes waste their twenties
getting over personal problems they
should have gotten over in their teenage
years
and
so
she did me a favor by putting something
down on paper young people have no idea
the importance of letters they think of
tweets and they think of emails
even just to get a job you write a
thorough deliberate letter it stands out
like this
even more now because everybody's using
email
las vegas keith good afternoon
hi thank you for taking my call
mr nader i'm surprised to hear you say
that our country is a democracy when it
is not it's a republic
and there's a world of difference
between a democracy and a republic
in a democracy the people can vote on
any issue but in a republic the people
vote for people who then gets to say
what happens
so basically all you have to do is
provide 535 members of congress and you
can do whatever you want to the other
300 million
no you're right uh i i don't i try not
to say we're a democracy because we're
basically a constitutional oligarchy and
the founding fathers knew what they were
doing they were very afraid of quote the
mob
and although there are some great
statements by thomas jefferson
hamilton and others knew what they were
doing and that and they that's why they
had a republic
which basically
delegates our democratic rights small d
to fewer and fewer people who then are
intercepted by the fat cats and pointed
that out however we are entitled to use
words like
democratic processes
electoral
rules
to indicate the the need to insinuate
different kinds of democratic
institutions in our country that are
accountable
to the people arthur robbins is about to
come out with a spectacular book maybe
in a year where he talks about ancient
athens and how far in advance so they
did have slavery etc but for the people
who were called citizens and is
remarkable how they insisted on a large
percentage of their citizens engaged in
the processes of discovery uh argument
debate and and self-government and
another book came out which i just
discovered called the people themselves
by professor larry kramer of nyu law
school and he showed how fundamentally
radical in a democratic sense
our colonial citizens were before 1787
in the constitution and how wonderfully
democratic even in your sense
the pennsylvania constitution was before
it was buckled under by the u.s
constitution and it's amazing how we we
learn about the colonial periods against
king george and the stamp tax and the
tea party there is tremendous ferment
because they hated the monarchy over
them in terms of local self-government
and participation and how radical they
were and how they they opposed our u.s
constitution
because they thought it was too
oligarchic too
remotely representative
too
uh distance from the will of the people
uh in spite of the preamble starting
with we the people not we the
corporation
so i'm glad you make that point but
remember democrat words can be used
other than just
relating to the republic structure that
we have you can have democratic unions
for example you can have initiative
referendum recall for example you can
have democratic cooperatives a model of
economic
delivery that is given too too little
attention today
ralph nader why did you put the
autobiography of benjamin franklin as
one of your favorite books
because it's the demonstration of the
power of self-education from someone who
came from nowhere
he basically almost walked from boston
to philadelphia before he was a teenager
he was curious he was observant he
taught himself and in all this talk
about education and i just heard
secretary duncan on c-span in his speech
there is never any reference to
self-education which eventually is of
course the only way you learn
but that becomes a consequence of a
bureaucratic process of education when
it should be
the progenitor and so anyone who wants
to
teach their children
should learn from the autobiography of
benjamin franklin who by the way cut it
off by the time he's 59 because he had
to go to france he had other things
to deal with it is just about 220 pages
it's out in paperback
it is
it's
you you're just awestruck by this mind
he ended up
becoming a member of the british academy
of sciences he was considered a
legitimate scientist in those days
member of the lightning and lightning
rod and so on
he once said to someone he was born too
early in the wrong century because he
saw the expansion of scientific
achievement that he wanted to be a part
of diplomat
writer negotiator merchant
inventor
i mean just
self-taught became the citizen to go to
in philadelphia he's the one who
launched the post office he launched the
volunteer fire department
and who are our heroes today for our
young generation britney spears snooki
uh what's uh what's the latest on lady
gaga
misbehaving athletes
misbehaving hollywood stars this is what
we're putting because they make a lot of
money in front of our people
young people
at their formative age
we let corporations raise our children
direct marketing under undermining
parental authority junk food junk food
junk drink more obesity violent
programming and the parents are busy
commuting back and forth sometimes with
two jobs to make the bills and they're
they're watching their children being
raised by commercial
giants who just want to squeeze more
money out of them or get them to nag
their parents to go to mcdonald's or
whatever
we have to take control
we have to cease
feeling powerless
and realize that the people have the
power as patty smith's song so well
sings it so what about homeschooling
fine if people want to homeschool fine
but i see young professional mothers for
example who are lawyers or phds they
fall right into the trap
and they run around and they have no
time for themselves they leave no
solitude for their children everything's
programmed the soccer this the swimming
meet 30 miles away 60 miles for a music
lesson and then homeschooling
homeschooling should allow more solitude
more contemplation more connection with
nature around
you know in the hills and the valleys
and the rivers so you know the geography
of where you live
but i think homeschooling is a
is a good option for parents brandt in
nashville tennessee you're on book tv
with ralph nader hi
yes thank you for your service ralph i
was wondering if you could speak towards
the globalization and monopolization of
the agriculture industry
and in regards to earth democracy
what
what you think about a water party how
do we get
people motivated to take their civic
responsibility
and preserve their most basic
their most precious
at least valued utility
huge area very important
the united nations assembly with the us
and canada abstaining
passed a resolution declaring that water
is a human right not access to a private
water company that charges them so much
but water
potable water
is a human right that's a good uh
decision uh in the last few days led by
maude barlow who's a great public
citizen of canada who's an advisor to
the u.n on this
uh we need to know what's happening to
our food we have some wonderful writers
eric schlosser michael pollan
and others that are taking insight and
declaration into what's happening to our
food industrial agriculture cramped pigs
cramped chickens high levels of
antibiotics in the feed as a
to try to head off sickness but it ends
up some of it in our own bodies uh
creating more bacteria resistance
industrial agriculture stripping family
farms putting them up against the wall
denuding the family farm
agriculture that's another area
supersize me was a good documentary that
some of you may have seen
and then of course the chemicalization
of the food
the inadequate scientific discipline
over genetic engineering of food all
these should be political issues all
these should be debated they're on a lot
of people's minds organic agriculture is
expanding farmer markets are expanding
very good it obviously reflects a sense
of caution and worry by people and we
still don't have a strong food safety
law and we're still not spending enough
for food safety inspectors by the fda
although there's a there's a bill on the
way if the senate can ever
pass it
7 000 people die every year in america
from contaminated food
700 000 are hospitalized and 70 million
get ill
i think that should be a priority i
don't think we need another nine billion
dollar aircraft carrier when we have no
major enemy left in the world
that requires its utilization i don't
think we need another nuclear submarine
i think we've got to shift that
that military budget in significant
amounts
back here at home for the american
people
david from arizona emails in imagine
that you've been invited to attend a
constitutional convention as a delegate
what three changes would you be an
advocate for
only
[Laughter]
well one we'll limit it to three one is
to
subordinate the corporation as an
artificial entity strip it of its
personhood it should not have
rights to engage in politics or
to lobby or to finance
uh candidates
the employees of a corporation have full
rights but not the artificial entity
that is a creature of the state
uh an imagination of the law as judge
justice marshall said so many years ago
so i would put the corporation back in
the corporate in the constitution or
that it doesn't exist it's been given
judge made powers strip it of its
personhood
subordinate it to the sovereignty of the
people as implied and we the people
make it more accountable more open the
larger it is the more accountable it
must be give more power to investors
shareholders to community rights when
there's toxic uh
pollution for example uh
worker rights and so forth
unless we subordinate the corporate
energy to the sovereignty of the people
the sovereignty corporations will
subordinate the people
the second thing i would do
is clean up our elections they are an
atrocity they can't even count the votes
accurately candidates are excluded
people don't have much rights in court
to challenge these systems so i would do
that and there's no time to go into all
that detail but it would be more
proportional representation instant
runoff voting an issue of referendum
recall voluntary public financing of
campaigns with a good check off on the
1040 tax return free access for
qualified candidates for on television
and radio the third thing i would do
is empower people
rights are not enough without remedies
we know that you can have the right to
vote but if
if the candidate is in the pocket you
don't have a remedy once the candidate
gets elected
and remedies without facilities don't
work this is this is a facility this in
effect makes it easy for people to band
together whether
as insurance
consumers banks consumers tenants voters
taxpayers people have different roles
at the same time and they need to band
together because
the corporations are organized to the
teeth
they have every cons conceivable
privilege and immunity that their power
can ring out of the government and the
people are not organized
and and that is why we have such a
imbalance of power and why the few
decide for the many so i would deal with
the facilities in a very extraordinary
manner
ralph nader we've listed a lot of books
a lot of websites is there an umbrella
place that people if they want to find
out about your books they want to find
out about your websites and all your
different arms of organization where
should they go
yes there is a website if you want to
get the book especially
only the super rich can save us you want
to get it autographed
the website is csrl.org
that's c as in cat s as in stamina
r as in ralph
l is in law c-s-r-l
dot o-r-g what does that stand for
center for a study of responsive law
next call for ralph nader noel in
florida or noel sorry
noelle you with us
i think she hung up barry san mateo
california hi yes hi uh thank you mr
nader for yours a thousand thanks the
question i wanted to ask or if maybe not
a question but i was wondering if you've
ever um
dealt with the the revealing of of
corporate uh
semantics and linguistics that could
possibly open up to the layman the
understanding of how they use words like
in the media and stuff to that mean the
opposite of of what they're really
saying it's like you know like like a
right-wing activist well i think that
was usurped from people in the 70s they
would never get you uh
use the word activism because activism
equaled left and i i'm probably not
wording it totally correctly but i was
wondering if any of your books address
these things uh
in the sense of the language that is
used by corporations to sit there and
actually pull one over on the people
where are you confucius now that we need
you
yes they do have their own language
you can get a good sample of that by
listening to the chairman of the federal
reserve
and they have their own language and
when they're asked mr chairman by the
joint economic committee what's the
state of the economy they will say the
state of the economy mr chairman is
sound and they will talk about
inventories and capital rules and
employment
not so much
and profits and sales and gdp
but they won't talk about other
indicators that have other language that
they would prefer not to use like child
poverty like consumer debt
now they have to talk about foreclosures
of course they won't talk about
corporate fraud
they won't talk about consumer
protection
they won't talk about
47 million people who make under 10
an hour before deductions they won't
talk about 50 million people who don't
have health insurance in other words
they select their indicators which are
seller side indicators not consumer side
indicators and then they wrap the these
elaborate
wall street
uh linguistics around them
and that of course restricts the
understanding of the public of what
they're up to and they're basically
talking code to a smaller and smaller
audience of commercialists
and
we've got to get them to talk plain
language
and that's why the people have to take
charge of their elections they have to
generate their own debates presidential
senatorial governor where they control
the debates in the various community
groups
who sponsor them don't let the
candidates control the debates
from the year 2000 ralph nader
put together this pamphlet cutting
corporate welfare
and here's what he proposes in this
legislation to cut corporate welfare
should number one eliminate below market
sales leases rentals loans technology
transfers and liability caps
too will not provide export assistance
marketing promotion research and
development for fossil fuels or nuclear
power
amend the irs tax code to eliminate all
corporate tax expenditures listed in the
president's annual budget and to count
his income the value of all local county
and state tax subsidies to for-profit
corporations
yes you know people are they're fighting
over whether taxes should be increased
or not on their income
why don't they fight about the
uncollected revenue
uh that uh corporations avoid or evade
pain tax havens in the bahamas for
example
uh million dollar plus million dollar
homes multi-million dollar homes where
they detect
the mortgage interest that wasn't
designed for them was designed for
ordinary homeowners
there's a a professor at uh mount
holyoke who has come up with an estimate
of a trillion dollars of uncollected
taxes like these tax expenditures which
people call tax loopholes and tax breaks
many of them corporate now here's my
idea which we discussed in the
presidential campaign but nobody paid
any attention
why not start taxing first
what society likes the least and
dislikes the most before you tax labor
workers for example
why don't we tax speculation derivative
taxation
600 trillion dollars of notional
derivatives last year imagine a tiny tax
on that would create hundreds of
billions of dollars they wouldn't even
feel it would be a fraction of one
percent
why should people go and pay seven eight
percent sales tax in the stores and
shopping malls for their necessities
when someone who monday morning is gonna
buy a hundred million dollars of exxon
derivatives it doesn't pay a cent in
sales tax
why don't we tax more corporate crime
tax pollution tax
carbon tax gambling you tax the things
that we like the least or dislike the
most suddenly we see our taxes going
down because the sheer velocity peter
of of the things we don't like that are
expanding
provide a very good basis for shifting
the tax burden to them one of my
favorite uh
one of my favorite stories is
how we give away our hard rock minerals
on our public lands do you know any
foreign company
like a canadian gold company
or domestic company can go on our lands
hire the geologists
document that our land has gold or
silver or molybdenum and they go to the
department of interior and under the
1872 mining act which should have been
repealed a long time ago
they get it for five dollars an acre
here's what happened
years ago in nevada
barrick
gold company from canada discovered nine
billion dollars worth of gold b by their
own sites they went with their
geologists department here department to
your hands are tied by the 1872 mine so
they said how many acres do you want
over the la over the mine so you can in
effect own and exploit the mine
they said we want x thousands of acres
they got it for thirty thousand dollars
the entire mine
and they're they're selling it off now
and i suppose they're going to leave
some waste behind cyanide lace and guess
who's gonna clean that up
when it reverts back to the
federal government that's our land and
our gold
untaxed only country in the world that
lets hard rock minerals be in effect
given away to corporations
michael frankfort kentucky hi
uh yes ralph one it's an honor to get to
talk to you and uh be on this program um
in 2000 uh you talked when you ran in
2000 you i watched you on c-span i was
quite amazed you talk about the
prevalence of injustice in our society
and yet
you know there were just massive
injustices everywhere how uh there was
so little being done about it well in
the last 10 years we've certainly seen
just an absolute explosion of injustices
um
and you know you mentioned like uh
shifting economic standards um but i
also wanted to talk about and ask you
about the shifting legal standards in
our country um i'm a graduate student
for computer science
um someday i'd love to go to law school
but the cost is just so tremendous um
could you talk about how like used to we
had the
we had like four legal standards
immunity reasonable man highest standard
of practice and strict liability
and it seems like now the corporations
in the government they're moving toward
immunity no matter how
how grossly negligent they are
there is a movement toward immunity
there's no doubt um
the bigger you are as a corporation the
bigger these government bureaucracies
become you can't reach them in the
courts they say you have no standing to
sue they say where are you going to get
the lawyers
and even if you sue them they're immune
uh even though under uh u.s legal
doctrine presidents and vice presidents
never
are immune from the criminal laws
whether they're in office or they're in
in retirement
and so i think you you make a point here
we have two classes now in our society
people who can be sued and people who if
they can't be sued can't be sued
effectively because they know how to
wear you down and attrition like these
corporate law firms representing these
companies against communities who are
trying to hold them accountable for
damage
so
and it's true increasingly
internationally as well
foreign corporations operate in this
country they have ways to avoid taxes as
they sell us goods and services it's
hard to reach them in terms of the arm
of the law
and now we have the world trade
organization in nafta where
these rules that are
developed these regulations that are
developed affecting workers and
consumers and communities in secret
they are secret and the appeals process
is secret in geneva switzerland they
circumvent our own
federal and state regulatory agencies
and courts
for example there's a law in this
country you cannot
sell a product made from child labor
it's almost 100 years old
but all over the world child labor
factories can sell products into the us
under wto and nafta because there's a
provision that says that
we cannot limit exports based on how
they're produced except for prison labor
abroad
so senator tom harkin wants to put a
bill in congress years ago to say
no imports from products made by
brutalized child labor the state
department and the trade rep says tom
you know what
don't bother putting it through congress
even if it passes it violates the wto
which is a uh which is a international
treaty that has the status status of
federal on it cannot be amended without
the consensus of all these other country
countries
you see why pat buchanan and i and
conservatives and liberals have doubts
about the wto well from the ralph nader
reader tools for regaining control of
what public already owns
let taxpayers sue the federal government
claim the airwaves with an audience
network and self-power consumer groups
that's from the ralph nader reader
number one is there anything there that
you think pat buchanan would disagree
with and this tweet has come in as has
have several related ones how about a
buchanan nader or nader buchanan ticket
well i think he's done with presidential
campaigning if you ask him he's done his
bit
um
first of all concentrate a little more
on local and state candidates there's a
great
candidate running
in manhattan jonathan tassini as a
democrat very progressive
former labor organizer there's a great
green party candidate in new york howie
hawkins i can't say enough good about
him former marine
citizen activist author thinker he's
running on the green party uh for uh for
governor
uh think of it think about that and just
remember aren't you glad some voters
split from the two parties in the 19th
century and voted for women's right to
vote and
the progressive income tax and 40-hour
week and anti-slavery
um
as far as uh
you know generally speaking
i think
we censor ourselves too much
and i think we ought to have uh
discussions where we say okay no more
self-censorship
okay uh president obama what do you
really think about the
israeli-palestinian issue did you really
want to support the invasion and
slaughter of palestinians in the gaza
invasion
surrounded by an illegal blockade and
blocking medicine and drinking water and
electricity and invading that area again
and again and saying oh those crude
rockets are the reason for all of this
don't palestinians have a right to
defend themselves you see how anathema
that is and yet a lot of the world sees
that reality as just described and if we
want a settlement of that problem with a
two-state solution we have to challenge
these politicians
and these corporate executives to drop
their self-censorship and start talking
publicly the way they talk privately
next call for ralph nader david tulsa
oklahoma hi
hi mr nader
i am a u.s history teacher and a u.s
government teacher to high school
students
if you were to
team teach with me for a year which
you're more than welcome to do
at the end of the semester what would
our students know what would our
classroom look like
what would tests look like what would do
you support
uh grades
uh and and what kind i just guess at the
end of the semester is what do you think
it is
critical that our students
would know
well i think first they they should know
the civic history of our country
uh which is quite different than a
political history it's often in the
shadows of historians work
and uh just ex and that's why um howard
zinn wrote his book the people's history
of the united states which i would use
as a as a textbook it's basically
a focus on the people who are never
mentioned our history the workers who
helped form the workers union
farm workers industrial workers people
who fought for
uh
women's right to vote
the people who established farm co-ops
and their own credit
uh
so much
of the wealth
of our country in a qualitative sense
has come from these forgotten people and
before the revolution in 1776 as well
and so i i would open up that whole area
i think it gives the students
encouragement it relates to them because
these are ordinary people
like themselves doing extraordinary
things i'd focus on the the youth
efforts in the 60s for example where
they went for more student rights they
demonstrated against the vietnam war
they pushed for the vote for to go down
to 18 years of age
uh they led so much of the civil rights
movement often were arrested and
imprisoned i think students were related
to that kind of courage and that
definition of of the heroic
uh i would take them to historic sites
but i wouldn't just let them gawk at
monuments like tourists do often here in
washington dc but i would make them
thinking tourists i would point out that
in oklahoma
you have a dominant uh
press baron the gaylord interests uh
that are not a very open to dissent you
have the worst ballot access laws uh to
keep people from uh being candidates at
the local and state and congressional
level who are not members of the
republican democratic party
and you have lost a sense of your own
history when you were one of the two
originating popular states that led the
populist movement that spread over most
of our country starting in 1887
and a lot of people in high schools
don't understand that and the entire
prepaid healthcare
movement in this country started with
the doctor michael shadeed a lebanese
immigrant came over when he was a young
teenager and literate and uh
was talk it was peddling at washington
university st louis and one of the
teachers saw his bright
insight
got him into school
he became
a doctor and and he went to the poor
farm areas of southwest oklahoma
around elk city and started the first
cooperative hospital in america and went
all over the country pushing for prepaid
medicine which led to the kaiser
permanente
and the uh
the
health co-op puget sound health co-op in
seattle that's great history it's never
written about go for it i wish i could
be in your class
from action for a change ralph nader
writes this country has more problems
than it should tolerate and more
solutions than it uses
scooter in las vegas you're on with
ralph nader
hello ralph it's a guilty pleasure being
able to
see you and listen to you today
i uh had a couple
uh thoughts and a question one was i
noticed that you
have a certain emotional attachment to
your
underwood typewriter
and i would consider that a guilty
pleasure
and also
i am curious as to
you had a very
formative dinner table discussion
each night
and uh you seem very attached to that
also it shows
yes i i think we always have to go back
to the shaping influences in our life
i think
youngsters today do not treasure they
may later in life
their parents best moments in wisdom and
insight and when they ask them to go
down to a a rally or to go down to a
town hall meeting and they say oh no
i've i've got a uh
i've got i got facebook or whatever
don't do that and i think parents have
got to take a stronger hold armor on the
shoulders my sister laura would often
say is is really important to my mother
used to
talk with young parents and say don't be
afraid of your children because they can
sense that once you are
you're in trouble and they're going to
be in trouble too
she used to interview my friends to make
sure i didn't fall in with a bad crowd
no nonsense interviews should give them
a lot of great food too during the
interview
i think also we need to
tap into the wisdom of the ancients
you know i uh they're great chinese
proverbs one of the best is to know and
not to do is not to know that was 14th
century during the ming dynasty just
think of that
to know and not to do is not to know
look at peter's point quoting me saying
we have more problems we deserve more
solutions than we apply we know so much
more we've got to liberate the energies
the civic and political energies of the
american people in order to bridge that
gap between knowledge and its
application
marcus cicero ancient roman lawyer he
had slaves to be sure as many did he
defined power as he defined freedom as
participation in power do we ever define
freedom that way how much freedom do we
have by that definition freedom is
participation and power
do we participate in
whether we go to war
what our tax system is like
what our election system is like whether
we can get on tv and radio which use our
property
you know whether we can have
alternatives to giant chain stores
don't remember that local hardware store
don't remember how
that that person would help us with our
problem try and find somebody in these
big hardware stores now
and tradition number two in the 17
traditions
was the family table just to take it
back to scooter
and also just to take it back to scooter
we have this email from chris in new
york city
you mentioned your vices which were not
many only an accumulation of too much
paper sometimes tending to disorder
is there's not something austere about
the model of public citizenship you
embody which might be off-putting to the
ordinary person who may be expected to
perceive from your example of severe
asceticism
and a lack of a
lack of enjoyment of life as a necessary
side effect of civic participation can
we just have a beer every once in a
while it's a brilliant observation and
in fact one of the mottos which got no
play in my 2004 campaign i said this is
a campaign of joy and justice
they wouldn't pick it up the press what
are you going to do you have to have a
you know small c type
uh slogan i guess i think that's true
but here's a way i would answer it first
of all i've been known to have
an extraordinary sense of humor it does
not display itself on soundbite tv and i
have been on saturday night live five
times and so you might glean at least
from the first time when i was a host uh
that there is a sense of humor there
i think in humor there's truth i think
there's
it's a great way of living
especially when you can turn it into
satire i think that's why a lot of
people watch
uh jon stewart and uh colbert
uh i think third
uh when you love justice it's joy it's
pleasure it's happiness it's almost
aesthetic
when you
get
letters from others who say their
children were saved by the seat belt
that's almost an aesthetic pleasure
and i know it's hard for people to
believe that unless they are involved
but if they are involved they know
exactly what i mean
do i overdo it i probably do overdo it
but the people who work with me don't
they have quite a bit of leisure time
they raise their families they have fun
they laugh they vacation
and i make sure that
to the extent that i've started all
these groups that that's the tempo i
just happen to be
a concentrator on the work i just think
there's a lot of work to do and a lot of
times you beat these big corporations by
working weekends
flagstaff arizona thomas
hello mr nader uh um
i appreciate and thank you for your
your knowledge on
all the subjects i've got a couple of
questions and a comment uh in regards uh
number one in regards to the immigration
issue
down here in arizona the boiling heart
issue of immigration and
institutionalized racism and
institutionalized colonialism i was
listening to you earlier you were
speaking about
benjamin franklin how he was a taught a
self-taught activist also
and also all myself taught the political
scientists i
i learned a lot of different uh
uh subjects and uh political science uh
and bear with me i'm a little nervous
but i'd like to know your uh uh your
opinion on the
issue of
the uh immigration issue in arizona and
also the plutocracy of the government uh
and also uh important uh idea i have is
uh where are we headed as a country uh
with all the problems that we're
facing and
all right you know what thomas a lot on
the table there ralph nader
from northern arizona a question that
invites more than sound bites
let me start this way on immigration
first of all i think we gotta
go through the history of our
colonial policies supporting oligarchs
and dictators in mexico and central
america and elsewhere
we're so deprived and starve their
people
that they have no
uh opportunity other than go north
across the river
to earn some money
illicitly but doing valuable work
growing our crops and other work
send money back to their families that's
where the pressure comes from if these
countries were more equitable and just
countries and had a better distribution
of power very few people want to come to
the united states and leave their native
country and their families let's never
forget that in the immigration debate
second i'm against brain drain
i think that we can't tell people in the
third world that they ought to have
opportunities for their scientists and
engineers and doctors and nurses and
entrepreneurs and then try to suck them
out of these countries into our country
for intel and cisco and microsoft and
others who should be advancing more
opportunities for minorities in this
country to become scientists engineers
doctors nurses and entrepreneurs
thirdly we should crack down on the
employers especially the large ones the
meat packing the chicken processing
tomato growers
who hire people who are here unlawfully
or undocumented and brutalize them
because they're so fearful these workers
that they can't speak up being paid
maybe two three dollars an hour not
being paid for weeks bad unsafe working
conditions while they produce the
necessities of life for the american
people like tomatoes and foodstuffs
fourthly what do we do about the people
who are here
and they don't have papers
and they're working if they're working
and if we don't want to put pressure
downward on
regular workers in this country
wages and standards we have to give them
equal standards equal labor equal
minimum wage etc because otherwise the
more who come in the more who are
employed unlawfully by these employers
the more downward pressure there is on
less jobs and lower standards and wages
for american workers
the bigger question of
controlling our borders to me should be
clear we have to control our borders we
have to control them for smuggling
for
disease and epidemic
for pollution which goes both ways we
have to control them for contraband we
have to control them for national
security anybody who thinks like the
wall street journal who loves open
immigration because that keeps workers
down and in their place
anybody who thinks that we shouldn't
control our borders is missing a very
important indicia of national
sovereignty what do we do with the
people who are already here they're
already working they're already in in
effect given an equitable residence
we've got to find a way where if they
don't want to go back
we find a way where in a responsible
fashion that has been laid out by some
legislators
they're given residents
papers
you know there's an equitable doctrine
peter that they may come in illegally
which is a misdemeanor not a felony
and then after years when they're
working and they're paying
withholding taxes and social security
that inequitable doctrine comes in of
basically rationalizing their presence
here
and so in a court of equity we have to
face up to that i mean now imagine if i
was asked on face the nation that
question i wouldn't be given the time to
ask that question it would be a bunch of
sound bites and then an interruption
that's why c-span is such a rare bird
ralph nader you are currently reading
who's canada
what is that book about it's a book
about canada and its loss of
independence
by
trade agreements
by absentee corporate ownership of their
minerals and and other assets in canada
about the need for them to reassert
uh domestic initiatives economically
and and especially
to ask the question
why should canada remain independent
we got a lot of good ideas from canada
they brought credit unions here 50
million members
years ago started in canada first radio
broadcast canada uh universal healthcare
canada and we did a book called canada
first
which by the way
took a while to get published in canada
because canadians are so modest they
don't care where they're first
and it became a 40 43 week bestseller in
paperback in canada so canada i think
we've got a lot to learn from canada and
the more we try to dominate it the more
we stuff stifle their innovation and
initiative we're gonna pay a price as
well how is the us stifling canada
well first of all corporate imperialism
i mean they have so much of their
economy now where the decisions are made
in new york chicago or london
and that's not healthy it's not healthy
for us if we
surrender that kind of economic
self-determination
second
culture
i mean it's all hollywood over there
they tried in montreal and quebec is the
french speaking to sort of say hey we
have our own culture you know let us do
our own movies
the canadians get so frustrated to go to
hollywood to create the movies you know
so many movies lorne michael for example
has been the head of saturday night live
he's a canadian
so
and and then there's a group that we
helped start called democracy watch led
by duff connector in ottawa this trying
basically uh to
not
adopt the
uh
suppressive restrictive
standards rules that we have on on
elections and on consumer rights and and
honesty in government and develop their
own native uh
processes and accountabilities
especially like he wants to have a crime
for a politician to lie
he wants to have a court say we're going
to adjudicate whether this politician is
lied to the people
duff connector congresswatch.ca
a one-man operation such as the country
of canada has never seen
okay once again you've named another
website but there's an umbrella website
that where you can branch out correct
csrl.org
csrl.org and i'd be very happy to send
you this book i really want you to see
how you can do your own writing and
offer this
you know stimulus called only the super
rich can save us which is
by the most recent and yeah it is a not
a novel but it's not non-fiction yeah
it's called the work of political
imagination
leslie stahl by the way of cvs 60
minutes read it on her vacation
and she wrote me a letter she said dear
ralph i read and i read and i read it's
the long book it is a the print is large
though it did it's a rather thick book a
lot smaller than iran's book what what
book are you and she said and she said
i found the engrossing creative and
funny and i said leslie i'll take all
three given the size
have you read iron ran
i skimmed it i find it abhorrent i
really do i find just the ideas i find
the idea of maximum narcissism
destructive of any sense of community
basically omnicidal if you extrapolate
it across the globe
i think she so adversely reacted and she
needed to react to her
communist you know the communist
countries where she came from
she vastly overreacted but she got a lot
of young people reading it and i want a
lot of young people to read only the
super rich can save us
what are you working on now book wise
well i'm working on a lot of things
involving congress you know and uh
health care energy is there a book and
arrest yeah i i uh i basically don't
talk about books until
they're finished because i want to get
them finished before i talk about them
how's that for circular reasoning
but i'll tell you one thing about it
i it's a book written to generate reader
indignation
based on evidence
sufficient enough
to break their routine
roll up their sleeves and become
civically and politically active
so it's basically a book to generate
a controlled rage
where they take away from it
invincible evidence
surrounded by irresistible rhetoric
i don't know if it's going to work or
not but at the end of the book i'm going
to give them an opportunity to band
together with a million americans
and devote 100 a year and 100 volunteer
hours around the whole platform and
agenda
of redirecting our country and pulling
it back from its downward slide
a vast majority of people think america
is heading in the wrong direction i
think the last poll a year goes 81
which is quite serious
75 percent think of corporations have
too much control over their lives
and in one poll 61 percent believe both
major parties are failing
so i think there's a lot
bigger consensus in this country
then the commercial dividers on cable tv
give us
allowance to believe exists
gregory in sherman oaks california
thanks for holding you're on with author
ralph nader
hello mr nader hi
hi i'd like to suggest uh your
consideration of an additional and for
many people
more accessible form of presentation of
some of your books and of the array of
ideas and programs they contain be my
guest
such as the agenda and platform for
america you you just mentioned
um an idea that in fact would be good
for many non-fiction ideas oriented
books which here you could hereby help
initiate namely
presenting this useful material on
well-designed posters and on large
two-dimensional surfaces
of both paper and scrollable web pages
everything from lists to timelines to
agendas
for display on classroom walls and walls
at home and in hallways stairways and
other public services
and in the process getting these ideas
across more universally
and to more people in these attention
fragmented time times of ours
just
contact us at
csrl.org
you know listening to him make that
proposal because i'm anything but
artistic i don't really know graphics
but now there's so many brilliant ways
to bring information in a exciting
manner graphic visual
imagery
accurate
that when i hear him describe that
especially getting it into the homes and
into the classrooms
uh i'm reminded of this phrase that we
all know
none of us comes close to being as smart
as all of us
that's why democracy is so appealing to
people they intuit that
no one is close to being as smart as all
of us
and so i hope to hear more from you and
i hope to hear more from other people
who have suggestions ideas actual
operating activities in their hometown
historical contemporary artistic
environmental educational name it want
to hear from you i also want to hear
from super rich people
because i can give them some suggestions
in terms of existing models of their
fraternity how they can break their
stereotype and become tribunes for
justice
and be able to look at their
grandchildren and great-grandchildren in
the eye
have you ever had a conversation with a
warren buffett or a bill gates after the
book came out i had breakfast with
warren buffett in uh omaha he's quite
intrigued by the book he is omaha yes
as a matter of fact
he told me that's the first time i
learned he was trying to get
billionaires all over the world
multi-billionaires to dedicate 50
of their estate to charity or good works
as he said then he smiled and he said we
have to figure out what good works are
and uh
and he he really means business he's
working with bill gates on this
and he really means but look super rich
people helped fund the anti-slavery
abolition movement out of boston rich
families helped fund the civil rights
movement the stern family the curry
family in the 50s and early 60s there's
a precedent there are a thousand rich
people trying to preserve the estate tax
from being eliminated even though they
would have to pay more
they have a public philosophy that shows
that nobody does it by themselves and
bill gates senior who's one of the 17 in
my book
has written a book on this with chuck
collins
you see
we've got to get out of our cocoons get
out of our routines
open it up
as we open it up we extend our own
capabilities
to our
immense surprise
that's how much potential there is to
unlock and it starts with the will to
break the routine of normal days to the
extent you can
and to experience new experiences and
interface
with new provocations and stimulus so
back to breakfast with uh warren buffett
what was that like what was your
conversation well first of all i ordered
a very small breakfast because i wanted
to do some talking too
[Laughter]
he told me a lot of interesting things
he had come to washington
a few months earlier
and met with democratic senators
looked him in the eye
and said
you're not taxing the super wealthy
enough like me
he said my secretary pays a higher tax
rate than i do
and that's not fair
so what did these democratic senators do
some of them thought he was from mars
and were bemused and others figuratively
backed away from him like he had
contagious tuberculosis he was a man
willing to lead
a man of great credibility
and they essentially turned his turn
their back on him
that's how cowardly the so-called
liberal
democratic party has become
that's why we need
third party and independent candidates
to challenge them and the republicans
but breakfast with buffett
is very good he doesn't dominate the
conversation
he's got a playful mind
and he's got a lot of good instincts
obviously he wants to make a lot of
money he's the toughest nails
guy in the marketplace sometimes doing
things that i don't think should be done
in terms of
uh public utility holding companies and
so forth but
he's devoted 36 billion in installments
to the gates foundation
and if he monitors that more and gives
more people an opportunity to do what he
wants done like completely overhaul the
tax system which we want to do imagine a
billion dollars to organize districts
all over the country from warren buffett
to overhaul the tax system
so there's a lot there
if
we're losing the charity race in this
country
look at poverty
look at hunger
we've got to go to the justice race
which prevents the conditions
that require charity a society that has
more justice is a society that needs
less charity
every time you run for president there's
talk about your personal wealth as well
yes you're a multi-millionaire well i
wouldn't put it that way
i reported about three million dollars
which i raised through writing lecturing
and a couple good investments which are
all declared
but why do i have that i have that for
several reasons i have that for a
defense fund
there's a lot of frivolous
activity that can go on by these
corporations
i have it in order to be able to engage
in pioneering
initiatives that nonprofits should not
be
able to engage in because they're tax
exempt
and i have it because i want to be able
to pay my bills i have individual
products like i helped start with my
personal money than the public interest
research group movement all over the
country person the perks that came that
was five hundred thousand dollars for my
lecture fees that helped get that
underway and they're training thousands
of
students in civic skills and involvement
in their community
in states like massachusetts new york
california michigan
and elsewhere
now that is not something that a
non-profit could have really done in the
period of nixon
if you know what i mean so
that's that's why i live on a very small
budget i don't have a yacht i don't own
property and um
maybe i'm too aesthetic for some from
some of the callers
but it's all designed to support our
groups and to support our missions bob
in hurley new york thanks for holding
you're on with author ralph nader
hello mr nader it's a pleasure to
hear you over these uh last three hours
and i'm a big supporter and have voted
for you each time you've run and if you
do run again you will have my vote um i
say you're the dalai lama of democracy
and
and um the last time i met with you was
in sherman connecticut in 2008
um and i gave you a t-shirt that i had
designed i thought was appropriate
especially for someone like you said
lower your karma footprint t-shirt
and uh something that i did at any rate
my question for you today is you know
the economy looks like this is going to
be an ongoing situation and your
thoughts on maybe some short-term
medium-term and long-term uh commitments
to fix this and i just want to thank you
once again from the bottom of my heart
yes i think first of all we have to
rearrange our tax system fast and raise
large money from things we don't
particularly like and we want to
diminish like reckless speculation with
other people's money by wall street
bosses and brokers
we need to put that money into public
works our country is in disrepair all
you got to do is ride around your city
town kanye and you say that should be
repaired it should be upgraded this
should be added to
and that's very very important for our
private economy public works is an
unsung hero for uh the elaboration
historically of our private uh economy
just think of canals think of
roads and bridges and transit systems
and
electrical grids etc so
not to mention other things like
libraries and clinics and schools so
that's the second thing i would do the
third thing is i would help to reduce
the deficit by
ending almost all corporate welfare
subsidies handouts and giveaways that's
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
the fourth thing is i would have more uh
more law enforcement against people who
don't pay their taxes and they're not
just people trying to make it through
life on twenty thousand a year you know
who i'm talking about a lot of them are
these partnerships these big
partnerships who've rigged the tax laws
and exploited them beyond the range of
mere avoidance and they've gotten into
evasion
and the tax havens etc
that's and of course
i would redirect more of the healthcare
dollar to prevention nutrition exercise
less use of useless ineffective harmful
pharmaceuticals uh more interaction with
with the bounties of nature
starting with our school starting with
the obesity uh problem that's just a few
but above all i would begin to enforce
the law on the powerful and the wealthy
and not just
let them get away with what they're
getting away with at the expense of the
american people
last call for ralph nader comes from
richard in haverhill massachusetts go
ahead richard uh thanks a lot peter
ralph this is an honor to talk to you
you certainly were blessed with
wonderful parents uh you and your sister
they certainly instilled wonderful
values in you too
but ralph uh what i'm calling about is
uh
for six out of the eight years that the
republicans controlled the congress and
the executive branch
the republicans uh didn't uh have any
checks on on on on mr bush they rarely
had any hearings on any of the issues
and i see the democrats kind of doing
the same thing i mean uh the senate the
senate relations committee should have
had hearings on this escalation before
they were going to escalate uh into the
war in afghanistan
so many things that
that obama's doing they're not even
calling them on not only speak to the
fire for instance
warmness wiretapping is still going on
yes and he has a right to uh if he
thinks that american abroad is helping
the terrorists he has the right to
assassinate them without any uh trial or
anything and also in the bargain air
force base okay richard we need to come
to a conclusion here i think what he i
think what he's saying is uh peter i
think what he's saying is there is an
unsavory continuity between bush and
obama on many military and foreign
policy issues and civil liberties issues
the bush the the obama administration is
is defending secret uh evidence uh the
in courts
they are still wiretapping
they do think they can go after any
american citizen abroad
without
due process due process
they've expanded the war in afghanistan
they're killing civilians and saying oh
sorry
so sorry terrorism
the drones are missing misfiring besides
are these people really suspects are
they turned in by bounty hunters or
people who have grudges in those local
communities uh it's a terrible situation
and it comes back to congress congress
is basically the upholder of
constitutional authority and restraints
on the executive branch and we've got to
create a groups that monitor congress
and push those members of congress so
there'll be no more undeclared wars no
more rubber stamping of military
appropriations not even hearings like
the assessments for iraq and
and afghanistan and
a full assumption of constitutional
duties by the one branch of government
our framers thought was most responsive
to the american people the congress
final email austin marinelli havertown
pennsylvania mr nader what if anything
gives you hope and optimism for the
future of this country and the world in
general ps you have my vote for
philosopher king well the first is how
much good has been done by a tiny few
people who represent larger public
sentiments throughout our history and
right now in america to local
communities around the country what if
we did more we'd get more justice number
two we have tremendous technological
capabilities that are often corporatized
rather than popularized such as solar
energy and other forms of public transit
so we're not using that it's on the
shelf and number three we have a hunger
for justice we have a hunger for justice
by the american people which needs to be
given voice institutional elaboration
outside of politics so they can shape
the electoral system so we really become
a government of buying for the people
here are ralph nader's books beginning
in 1965 unsafe at any speed
whistleblowing action for a change the
big boys
lemon book
winning the insurance game
canada first
collision course
no contest
the ralph nader reader
cutting corporate welfare crashing the
party
in pursuit of justice
the good fight
civic arousal
the 17 traditions and only the super
rich can save us if people want more
information ralph nader what's the
website one more time
csrl.org thank you for being our guest
on in depth thank you very
much we offer you another chance to view
in depth with author and consumer
advocate ralph nader in its entirety
next saturday at 9 00 a.m eastern
you